Andrew Huberman: [Music Playing] Welcome to the Huberman Lab
Guest Series, where I and an expert
guest discuss  science and science
based tools for everyday life.
I'm Andrew Huberman, and I'm a Professor
of Neurobiology and Ophthalmology
at Stanford School of Medicine.
Today marks the third episode
in our four episode series
about mental health with Dr.
Paul Conti.
Today's episode deals with the topic
of healthy relationships, how to
define what a healthy relationship
is, and how to achieve healthy
relationships of all kinds, including
romantic relationships, interpersonal
relationships at work, friendships with
family, and of course, with oneself.
This episode builds on the framework
of the psychology of self and mental
health that was established in the first
and second episodes of this series.
However, even if you didn't listen to
the first or second episode in this
series, today's episode will still
contain a lot of information and
protocols that you will find valuable
for improving your relationships.
That said, if you have the opportunity to
listen to the first and second episodes in
this series, I think you'll find those to
be tremendously beneficial at any point.
During today's episode, Dr.
Conti discusses what makes for
a successful relationship of
any kind, as well as tools to
improve those relationships.
He discusses various types of bonds,
including healthy bonds and trauma
bonds, not just in the context of
romantic relationship, but in the
context of all types of relationships.
We also discuss different challenges
that people face in relationships,
including abusive relationships, and
we discuss the role of power dynamics,
anxiety, and boundaries in relationships,
both from the perspective of unhealthy
relationships, but more importantly
from the understanding and protocols
to cultivate healthy relationships.
While there is an abundance of opinions
and information out there on the Internet
these days about relationships both
healthy and unhealthy, today's discussion
approaches the topic of relationships
through an entirely different lens, which
is the lens of the self in terms of one's
conscious and subconscious mind, and how
multiple conscious and subconscious minds
through different individuals, interact
with one another in ways that we can see
and ways that we can't see, and all of
that framed within the actionable steps
that any of us can take to improve our
relationship to ourself and to others.
Before we begin, I'd like to emphasize
that this podcast is separate from my
teaching and research roles at Stanford.
It is, however, part of my desire and
effort to bring zero cost to consumer
information about science and science
related tools to the general public.
In keeping with that theme, I'd like to
thank the sponsors of today's podcast.
Our first sponsor is BetterHelp.
BetterHelp offers professional
therapy with a licensed
therapist, carried out all online.
I've been doing therapy
for more than 30 years.
While I confess that initially I was
forced to do that therapy as a condition
for being let back into high school,
over time I learned that therapy is
a tremendously valuable practice.
In fact, I consider doing regular
weekly therapy just as important
as doing regular physical exercise
in order to improve one's health.
The beauty of BetterHelp is that it
makes it extremely easy to find a
therapist that's excellent for you.
And we can define an excellent
therapist as somebody who's going to
give you a lot of support, but in an
objective way as well as somebody with
whom you can have excellent rapport,
a nd that can help you arrive at
positively transformative insights
that you wouldn't have otherwise had.
And with BetterHelp, they make
it convenient so that it's
matched to your schedule and
the other aspects of your life.
If you'd like to try BetterHelp,
go to betterhelp.com/huberman,
to get 10% off your first month.
Again, that's betterhelp.com/huberman.
Today's episode is also
brought to us by Waking Up.
Waking Up is a meditation app that
offers dozens of guided meditation
sessions, mindfulness trainings,
Yoga Nidra sessions, and more.
By now, there's an abundance of data
showing that even short daily meditations
can greatly improve our mood, reduce
anxiety, improve our ability to
focus, and can improve our memory.
And while there are many different
forms of meditation, most people
find it difficult to find and stick
to a meditation practice in a way
that is most beneficial for them.
The Waking Up app makes it extremely
easy to learn how to meditate and
to carry out your daily meditation
practice in a way that's going to be
most effective and efficient for you.
It includes a variety of different types
of meditations of different duration,
as well as things like Yoga Nidra, which
place the brain and body into a sort of
pseudosleep that allows you to emerge
feeling incredibly mentally refreshed.
In fact, the science around Yoga Nidra is
really impressive, showing that after a
Yoga Nidra session, levels of dopamine in
certain areas of the brain are enhanced
by up to 60%, which places the brain and
body into a state of enhanced readiness
for mental work and for physical work.
Another thing I really like about
the Waking Up app is that it provides
a 30 day introduction course.
So for those of you that have not
meditated before or getting back to a
meditation practice, that's fantastic.
Or, if you're somebody who's already a
skilled and regular meditator, Waking
Up has more advanced meditations and
Yoga Nidra sessions for you as well.
If you'd like to try the Waking Up app,
you can go to wakingup.com/huberman
and access a free 30 day trial.
Again, that's wakingup.com/huberman.
And now for my discussion
about mental health with Dr.
Paul Conti.
Dr.
Conti, welcome back.
Paul Conti: Thank you.
Happy to be here.
Andrew Huberman: Today we're going to
discuss relationships, and that will
often focus on romantic relationships,
but also relationships between friends,
between family members, and inevitably,
the relationship to self, which is what
we really focused on in episodes one
and two of this series, episode one
being all the things that go into a
healthy self and how to understand what
is unhealthy and healthy in all of us
and make adjustments to the unhealthy
aspects of our unconscious and conscious
through really specific proactive
behaviors and patterns of thought.
So really a roadmap to these
ideals that we call mental health
and understanding of the self.
Today we want to talk about
relationships from the perspective
of, of course, how people relate.
But I have a feeling it's going to have
something to do with, or perhaps almost
everything to do with our relationship,
to understanding ourselves first.
Paul Conti: Yes.
Andrew Huberman: So, just to make
sure that we're all on the same page,
regardless of whether or not people
have seen episodes one and two, and
certainly people do not need to have
seen or listened to episodes one and two
of this series in order to understand
today's discussion, could you please
tell us what is a healthy person?
And how can we ask ourselves the sorts
of questions that allow us to determine
whether or not we are healthy and where
to look in terms of making adjustments
if we want to be healthier than we
already are, which I have to believe
almost everybody, if not everybody,
certainly wants to be the healthiest
and best expression of themselves
so that they can do the most for
themselves and for others in the world?
Paul Conti: So, the linchpin of it all,
is the agency and gratitude as verbs.
That's the top of the mountain.
There's a lot of climbing we do
to get to the top of the mountain.
Once we're over the top of the mountain,
then things are in a better place.
And even though there are two words,
agency is, of course, a word, g
ratitude is a word, b ut it doesn't
mean that they're separate concepts.
Approaching the world through the lens
of agency and gratitude, thought of as
one thing because they come together
and they come together as verbs.
That's what we're aiming for, because
that's the thing that we can work towards.
If you think about what comes
underneath that, it takes us back to
the two pillars and the 10 cupboards.
And if we're looking in there enough,
we're mInding, like what is in my
unconscious mind I might not be aware of.
Let me generate some curiosity
about my defense mechanisms and
my character structure and think
about what's salient inside of me.
If we're doing all of that, then
what we're doing, we're building
empowerment, we're building humility.
And then ultimately, the expression
of all of that is the agency and
gratitude, and it's something
that we can't have enough of.
Like I say, what's the
best amount of that?
The most that's possible, right?
Because we're going to engage in
the world in the healthiest way.
Because agency and gratitude doesn't mean
like, we're happy about everything, right?
If there's something negative
and we can change that, then
we don't feel happy about that.
The sense of gratitude in me
makes me more likely to feel
that I can change that, right?
Or to take the chance of
trying to change that.
And then the agency part of that
concept can come more to the
fore and I can make the change.
So it's not about bliss, it's not
about forgiving self and others
for all sorts of things and not
working to make things better.
It's about being in the world and
being as aware as I can possibly
be, including being aware that
there are things I'm not aware of.
So sort of having a healthy respect and an
orientation to the world that values truth
and values understanding and exploration.
If we do all of that, then we
reach the top of the mountain
through the agency and gratitude.
And then what builds upon that or
what comes from that is the peace,
the contentment, the delight, the
generative drive being strengthened
like that all comes together.
And then the aggressive, or we
say aggressive because that's
the traditional term, b ut the
aggressive or the assertive.
The assertiveness or assertion drive,
however, whatever word we want to put
to that, that drive exists in us in a
way that subserves the generative drive.
The same thing with the
pleasure drive in us.
It exists in us, but it's
subserving the generative drive.
And then all those good things come
together and they come together
to help us be as healthy as we can
and to stay healthy, including when
tribulation or difficulties come our
way, so that we stay as best we can
in the agency and gratitude as verbs.
And again, there's nothing
theoretical about this.
It's a way to live, and there are a lot
of people who live some of their lives,
or parts of their lives through that.
And we can aspire to it and we can work
towards it, and if we're the best that
we can be, then we're going to be in
our relationships the best we can be.
Think about it, like, you and I
have a relationship, we know each
other, w e're working together.
If I can bring my best self to
you, to thinking about you, to
understanding you, if I can bring
the agency and the gratitude,
then I'm going to do right by you.
I'm going to mentalize this
idea of thinking about what's
going on inside of you.
I'm going to bring the
best o f all of that.
And then, because we have a
relationship, t here's also an "us."
There's a me, there's a you, there's
something that happens between us.
That's the relationship, that's the "us."
And I will also bring my best self
to that thing that is no longer just
me or just you, but that is an us.
And that applies to all relationships.
You can apply that to seeking health in
every single relationship in our lives.
Andrew Huberman: What you're saying
really speaks to the importance of
people taking a real look at themselves,
which is not necessarily an inventory
of self in the typical sense that we're
used to hearing it, but rather through
this lens or map of the self that was
spelled out in episodes one and two.
And again, for those that are
just joining the series now, the
map, as we're referring to it,
is available as a downloadable
PDF in the show note captions.
If people want to get that,
it's completely zero cost.
You can just go there and access
it, or just view it on a screen,
print it out, whatever you like.
You certainly don't need to do that,
because here again, we're talking about
the core elements of that map, which,
if I understand correctly, arrive
eventually at a set of verb states that
we're calling agency and gratitude.
Those are not separate, as you
pointed out, they work together.
Paul Conti: You described it as
on top of the geyser, r ight?
And I really like that there's a
lot of things going on, but then
it all uplifts to something, right?
And if we're doing it in the right way,
in the diligent way, then i t is like
a geyser, a nd what it's lifting up on
top of it is the agency and gratitude.
I love that you put those
words to i t, and I think it
captures it really profoundly.
Andrew Huberman: Well, the stuff that
geysers up perhaps deserves a bit of
our attention just for a few moments.
You describe these two pillars
that I described as geysering up
into agency and gratitude in the
best circumstances, but in the best
circumstances, we want to remind
ourselves and everybody, are attainable
by looking at what's in those pillars.
Those two pillars are
the structure of self.
So really understanding something
about the structure of self.
So that includes some understanding of
the unconscious mind, some understanding
of the conscious mind, defense
mechanisms, character structure and self.
That was all reviewed and described
in episodes one and two, as well
as the functions of self, which
are more of the verb states, the
expressions of the structure of self.
Self-awareness being the first of
those defense mechanisms in action.
And here I'd be remiss if I didn't tell
myself and everybody else again that
defense mechanisms are not always bad.
There can be healthy defense mechanisms.
Paul Conti: Absolutely.
Andrew Huberman: They can
protect us in very valuable ways.
And then this notion of salience,
what we pay attention to, what
sorts of scripts are going on in
our head about ourselves and others,
what are we paying attention to?
How are we interpreting those in our
head and to others, and then most
importantly, perhaps to ourselves?
And then our actual behaviors, like what
we are doing from the time we wake up
until the time we go to sleep at night,
and then our strivings, our sense of
hopefulness, or perhaps lack of strivings.
And there I am reminded also
that nobody does all of these
things perfectly all the time.
We all have elements within us that
perhaps are not serving to geyser up
into agency and gratitude as well as
they could, but that all of us have the
capacity to look at these two pillars
and these 10 things that were just listed
off, as you describe them, as cupboards
that we look into and examine and think
about, and that if we can do that with a
skilled clinician like yourself or another
psychiatrist or psychologist, terrific.
But even if we don't have access
to that, we can examine within
us what is and is not serving to
geyser up into agency and gratitude.
Paul Conti: We can bring any issue
of self to those two pillars and
the 10 cupboards within them.
Any issue of self.
Why?
Because that's what it is, in
the s ense that it is the "us."
What's inside of me.
I have an unconscious mind, I have a
conscious mind, I have a defensive s
tructure, I have a character structure,
I h ave a self, that's what it is.
And all the functions that you
mentioned, they're all going on
within that structure of self.
They're manifesting themselves.
That's what it is w hen we're being,
in the active way of the verb being.
That's what it is, which is why
w e can bring to it any issue
of self, even though, of course,
there's tremendous complexity there.
The million things that go on in a
second underneath the surface in the
unconscious mind and our defensive
structures and how to see them.
But we're human beings.
We're complicated, right?
That's okay, because we have methods
of understanding, we have methods
of inquiry, and we can use those
methods to make things better.
And that's how we make the
geyser as strong as it can be.
Where maybe some of the water is
running countercurrent in the...
okay, well, let's try and have
things go all in the same direction.
But we don't need things to be perfect
for the geyser to spring up and the agency
and gratitude to then be uplifted upon it.
Andrew Huberman: So everybody has
one of these maps, as I understand
it, and therefore anytime we're
talking about relationships, romantic
relationships or otherwise, we're
talking about the intersection or
overlap of those maps in some way,
maybe even the synergy and the outgrowth
of those maps becomes its own map.
I think we'll get to
this a little bit later.
Paul Conti: Yes.
Andrew Huberman: When I and most
people hear the word relationships, in
particular romantic relationships, I
make a couple of automatic assumptions.
First of all, I have to assume
that people are either in a
relationship or out of a relationship.
There's probably a third category out
there of plurals and other things,
but we'll keep it relatively simple.
And most people, I assume, when they
search for or enter, or entered a
relationship, they thought about whether
or not they had resonance with the
person, whether or not there was an
intellectual or mutual interest resonance
or a physical resonance, maybe something
about family history, common goals, etc.
That's typically what people think about.
And then perhaps if people will have a bit
more of a psychological understanding, or
they're reading some pop psychology books
these days, some of which are pretty good,
they might understand something about
themselves or the other person being a
bit more anxious or a bit more relaxed.
So you'll hear things like
anxious, attached, secure,
attached, things of that sort.
If we could just step back from all
of that for a moment and examine it
through the lens of the maps as you're
describing them, which exist in all of us.
And that really are the map to
being the best version of ourselves.
If we look at relationships in terms
of lists of where people went to
school, if they went to school, are
their parents married or divorced?
Do they have trauma that they're aware of
or not aware of these kinds of things, I
guess we could call those, and here I'm
borrowing language that you used earlier
off-camera, so I want to acknowledge that.
Points of compatibility,
I think that seems like a
reasonable place to start, right?
Do people want the same thing?
So if you could, could you talk a
little bit about points of compatibility
in a relationship and how those
show up, for better or for worse?
When you encounter people in the clinical
setting, when you see somebody who's in
a relationship that's really working for
them and is healthy versus if they're in a
relationship where it's really unhealthy,
presumably there's some knowledge about
points of compatibility, but I'm guessing
that's not always intuitive, right?
Paul Conti: I think the place we
start there is acknowledging what
we can know and what we can't know.
So this idea that there are levels o
f emergence where things at a lower
level come together and create something
that's new, we see this throughout
science, from subatomic particles
all the way through to culture.
So someone could know theoretically,
lots and lots and lots about you
and lots and lots and lots about me,
but they don't know about us, right?
They don't know how we interact.
They don't know if we have shared
interests, what we talk about.
They don't know that.
No one knows that.
We don't know that about
the combination of people.
We can't know it in advance, but
we often believe that we can, which
then leads to a lot of false metrics
of trying to figure things out.
So when we're looking for compatibility,
the thought will be just very basic,
tangible things, like in romance,
for example, if there's someone who
absolutely wants to have a family
and there's someone who absolutely
does not want to have a family, okay,
that would be a reason for those two
people to not choose one another.
So there are these factors, but
the factors are all, in a sense,
very evident and very concrete.
If we go beyond that, we say,
okay, we can see the obvious.
Then what we're looking for is really
a compatibility of generative drives.
And then that tells you, can
these people then get along?
Maybe one of them is from one s ide of
the world and the other i s from the
other side of the world, or one's an
accountant and the other is a musician.
And it doesn't mean that they're built not
to get along or that if they're doing the
same thing they're built to get along, or
if they went to college in the same place,
or they went to college versus not going
to college, there's so much there that we
try to build a story on, and then what we
do is we miss the forest for the trees.
And the trees, I think, are
the factors that don't matter.
So again, let's think about
the factors that do matter.
Person wants to have a family,
the other person doesn't.
That's relevant.
But the trees that mislead us might be,
do they have the same level of education?
Do they have the same
family structure growing up?
Are parents still together?
What do they enjoy?
Are they creative or
scientific or whatever?
Or creatively scientific.
We could look at all of that,
but I think then we're making a
bunch of trees that mislead us.
If you say, look, do these people come
at the world through how much agency
and gratitude is there guiding them?
How high is the top of that geyser?
How high is it uplifting that?
How strong is the generative drive?
If we match people upon that,
then we see, oh, those people got
along and those people didn't.
And then there are all the other factors,
like pheromones, a nd things that we can't
understand or reflexive first impressions.
We could let things develop, honoring
the truth of what we can't know.
That when you put two people
together, you get something that's
different from the sum of both people.
It's not an overlap of maps, i t's a
new map, a nd the map is informed by
things that are on each individual's map.
But what we're looking for are maps that
don't have very significant differences
around just clear, concrete things.
But once we get beyond that, the maps can
synergize in all sorts of beautiful and
unpredictable ways, and if both are coming
from the perspective of a generative
drive that is at the forefront, great.
You put those maps together
and see what happens.
Maybe nothing happens.
Okay.
Those people don't go
out on a second date.
Maybe something happens, but it
doesn't develop in certain ways.
Okay, those people dated
and stopped dating.
Like, this happens all the time, r ight?
But we set the odds in our favor that
the generative drive in each that is
at the forefront means that their maps
can synergize in ways that can then be
beautiful and ways that can maybe bring
to both people that which they want.
And I think there's a simplicity
to that, that I think if we honor
it can be very, very helpful.
Whether it's romance, it's friendships,
of looking at what the truth of it
is instead of the factors that we try
and gain a false sense of security
if we're using them to select upon.
Andrew Huberman: You mentioned several
times the generative drive, and I
definitely would like to learn more
about that and spend some time there
in the context of relationships.
But just to drill a little bit
further into what we've all heard
so often, and you touched upon a
few of these themes around points of
compatibility, but also where sometimes
we can respond to the wrong things
when thinking about compatibility.
Again, we're framing this mainly
in the context of hypothetical
romantic relationships, but certainly
it pertains to other sorts of
relationships, things like, is one
person educated with an advanced
degree, and is the other person also?
We tend to assume that people
who are, are somehow a better
match than people who aren't.
That's sort of an implicit assumption
that's often made, not always.
Or that if two people really love music,
that they will enjoy music together,
and therefore the sum of the whole
is greater than either of its parts.
Paul Conti: And I think those
things are utterly irrelevant.
Andrew Huberman: Interesting, and I want
to hear more about this because I think
that if you think about, which I'm sure
you don't, but, like dating apps, for
instance, like what's listed out there
or first or second dates, which consists
of learning a little bit about somebody
and what they're doing and maybe even a
little bit about their history and maybe
an activity and certainly an intentional
awareness to how the other person is
behaving in the context of different
things, like a waiter or a waitress and
how they're treating people, and you.
And then you hear about things like...
this is not something I'm familiar with...
oh, right, the love languages.
People are like, oh,
what's their love language?
It's like gifts or, like acts of physical
touch or acts of service or something.
I met someone recently, and she told me
my love language is all of them, which I
think is the most honest answer, right?
Because, sure, there's probably some
weighting around what people value
more or less, and in the absence
of the things they value the most,
it would probably feel a bit like
deprivation in any relationship.
But as I'm describing all
this, I'm realizing more and
more, yes, all of that matters.
Anxious, attached, secure,
attached, love languages, etc.
But it really doesn't get
to the heart of the matter.
It really doesn't get to this, as
you're describing it, this generative
drive in individuals, and whether
or not those match up well along
the points of compatibility with
the other person's generative drive.
And I haven't run a controlled study
for this, but the best evidence I have
is that there, fortunately, are many
people out there who are in happy,
healthy relationships, but there
are many, many people who are not,
either because they can't find them,
or they're in them and they're not
healthy, or they're not happy, etc.
So if you could elaborate a bit
more on the generative drive, again
reminding us what the nature of that is.
We covered this a bit in episodes
one and two, but what the nature
of that is and some different ways
that that's expressed and how that
shows up in healthy relationship.
Paul Conti: Yeah, I think we really
disprove the idea that some of
these factors that I think are
superficial in the context o f whether
people are going to be compatible.
They're not superficial things,
but they're not germane.
So let's say you think about music,
and say two people are contemplating
romance, and they both really like music.
W ell, that could go very, very well.
Let's say they both have
a strong generative drive.
Those pillars are pretty healthy,
and the geyser of the agency and
gratitude is riding upon it, and
they can find peace in themselves.
They're strongly generative, then
they could become interested in
the music the other person likes.
There's not going to
be a complete overlap.
Even if people generally
like the same thing.
But let's say they like different things,
like just liking music, or even liking
the same music, there's still difference.
So the person has to go beyond themselves,
and say, okay, I'm interested in what you
think, even about the music we both like.
What factors do you like?
There are places of learning
and of growth for both.
And you could see how both liking music,
whether it's the same or different
music, that sounds great, right?
But you could also see how
that could not be great.
If the generative drive is too low
and the aggression drive is too
high, then I'm going to think, I like
music, my music is better than yours.
People then start, they'll fragment,
even though they have the same interest.
Or if the pleasure drive is too high,
then they think, I want to listen to
my music, not yours, I'm familiar with
it, instead of, hey, I'm interested in
that music because you're interested
in it, and I'm interested in you.
Which leads us to the second part.
Let's say you have someone who really has
no interest in music and someone who does.
Well, there can be an openness of saying,
if I'm interested in this person and
this person is really interested in
music, I have some interest in it, right?
I want to learn something about it.
I want to experience some
of it with the other person.
And let's say that person then
finds, hey, that's not my thing.
It's not the thing we connect
on, then, why would that be
the end o f the world, right?
P lenty of people, one person goes
to concerts, the other doesn't.
So we try to find these points of
commonality, because I think we
get over reductionist, and then
we think, oh, here's a bunch of
factors that we will identify.
And what they do is they obscure us
from the primary factor, which is the
generative drive, which, of course, will
then induce open mindedness mentalization.
If I don't like music and you do, instead
of saying, what do you like music for?
I need a friendship with
somebody who likes music.
You think, hey, that's interesting.
If I'm interested in you as a friend
and I have respect for you and what you
think, then why would I not have some
interest in what you're interested in?
So this idea of compatibility revolves
around the health in each person.
It doesn't revolve around factors
that are anything but the concrete
logistical factors that would
just keep two people apart.
Andrew Huberman: I love the idea that
healthy relationships center around the
factors that really matter within the
self, in particular the generative drive.
And I love the example of someone being
able to be curious about somebody's
interests, about their partner's
interests, even though they might
not share those from the standpoint
of agency and gratitude, because the
agency component there is really key.
I think that a lot of people feel
as if they aren't really good at
something or really knowledgeable about
something, then it's not for them.
Which is the opposite of
having agency and gratitude.
Because gratitude is
closely tied to humility.
How could we know everything?
It can be good, certain
things, and not others.
So the way you describe it includes
aspects of openness, of humility, but
also the agency side, the empowerment.
Like, if I'm going to learn
more, then perhaps we could
enjoy more of that together.
Perhaps not, right?
I think this is what I'm sensing, and I'm
also sensing that the words like-minded,
like-minded people has so much more to do
with their generative drives and how those
match up as opposed to the activities
that they prefer engaging in and the sorts
of foods they like or the movies they
like, which makes sense at some level.
But I think it is still counterintuitive
for a lot of us who just kind of
reflexively think, oh, they like the same
things, or maybe even they met at work
because they like the same type of work.
They like to live in a certain
area of the country, and
therefore, by proximity, they met.
And this raises all sorts of
interesting ideas, perhaps, about
the statistics of what we see.
Like two musicians together, we
therefore assume that musicians belong
together or two scientists together.
I know loads of scientist-scientist
couples or scientist-physician
couples, but of course, the numbers
are skewed because they were working
in environments where it increased
the probability they would interact.
So this is actually a vote for online
dating in some sense, because it breaks
through all those, sometimes even
geographical barriers, but certainly
the traditional barriers of culture.
Paul Conti: Right.
And if you think about it, we're
talking about relationships, so
I would like my relationships to
last as long as possible, right?
That means now we're talking about
my lifespan and my health span.
That then becomes part of that discussion.
And of course, we're very interested
in lifespan and health span.
And we see people do much, much
better when they're interconnected
in the world around them, when
they're still learning new things.
We know that's true, that people often
will tail, they sort of trail off of what
they're learning, whether it's music,
it's literature, it's the world around
us relatively early in our lifespan.
But the person who's interconnected
learning new things has a much
greater probability of living
longer and living healthier.
Right?
So think, what's that about?
It's about a generative drive.
It's about, you know what, I've learned
a lot of things over the course of my
life, and I'm 80 years old now, and
great, that there's more to learn, right?
And that's what you see.
It makes me think of a woman who's
around 90 years old in my practice.
She's always learning new things, she's
super interested in things and I'm always
struck by how she seems so much younger.
And there, that's not just a selection
bias, like, oh, I just happen to
see that in that person, she has the
factors that predispose to aging in
the way that's healthiest and happiest.
So it really comes down to, the root
of all of it, in ourselves, in our
relationships, in the quality of them
over time and how long we get to have them
really arises from a generative drive.
And that's the thing that makes us
then undefended, and lets us find
interest in things about other people
that are different from the things in
us, which also comes about naturally.
I think it's interesting that we
have this sort of bias, like I said,
that musicians belong together.
Well, why?
They're familiar with
the same things, right.
I guess they have the same interest,
same thing with scientists.
But then a lot of people
like different foods, right?
I love different ethnic foods.
Why?
Because it's different, right?
It's an appreciation of difference.
I don't want to eat just like I
did growing up and many, many,
many people are like that.
That's an appreciation of
difference, of diversity.
So sometimes we'll kind of harness that
and we'll look at it and we'll say, oh,
that's present in us, but for whatever
reason we become very reductionist
about relationships and now we're
trying to match based upon sameness,
and sameness is not the point of it.
I mean there are even thoughts
about people then in some way
seeking difference, and maybe
pheromones are telling us that.
I actually know very little about
that, but I certainly know that
striving for sameness doesn't make
good things happen in relationships.
I've been doing this for over 20
years and I don't see that the
alleged factors of sameness matter
again unless they're so concrete.
Like if this person is absolutely going to
live in North America and that person is
absolutely going to live in South America,
let's not potentially put them together.
But once we get away from almost that
level of concreteness, let's look
for something different, and then
like everything else, it simplifies.
The higher we go up the ladder,
the more simple things get.
If you're looking at the pillars,
structure of self, function of
self, you're creating the agency and
gratitude, then what are you looking
for when you're looking for a partner...
a match in generative drive.
I want mine to be strong and I see
that it's strong in this person.
They create in a way, you know what,
I do science, they grow a garden.
We're generative together.
Like that could be super compatible
because we're looking at the
one factor that really matters.
Andrew Huberman: I'd like to take
a brief break and acknowledge
one of our sponsors, AG1.
AG1 is a vitamin mineral probiotic
drink that meets all of your
foundational nutrition needs.
I started taking AG1 way back
in 2012, so I'm delighted that
they're sponsoring the podcast.
The reason I started taking AG1, a nd the
reason I still take AG1 once or generally
twice per day, is that it's the easiest
way for me to ensure that I'm getting all
of the vitamins, minerals, probiotics,
and fiber that I need in my diet.
Now, of course, it's essential to get
proper nutrition from whole foods,
but most people, including myself,
find it hard to get enough servings
of fruits and vegetables each day, and
especially to get enough prebiotics
and probiotics to ensure gut health.
As you may know, your gut contains
trillions of little microbiota,
the so-called gut microbiome, which
establishes critical connections with
other organs of your body to enhance
brain health, as well as to support your
immune system and other aspects that
relate to mental and physical health.
One of the most common questions I get is,
if you were to take just one supplement,
which supplement would that be?
And my answer is always AG1, because
by taking AG1, I'm able to ensure
that I'm getting all of the vitamins,
minerals, and probiotics that I
need to enhance my mental health,
physical health, and performance.
If you'd like to try AG1,
go to drinkag1.com/huberman
to claim a special offer.
They'll give you five free travel
packs, and they'll give you a
year's supply of Vitamin D3K2.
Again, that's drinkag1.com/huberman
to claim this special offer.
I'm realizing that most of what I
and everyone else has heard about
relationships is complete nonsense.
I really mean that.
I mean, it has occurred to me before
because I've experienced both that
the phrases 'absence makes the
heart grow fonder' and 'out of
sight, out of mind,' are in direct
contradiction with one another.
So they're both true, it depends
on the circumstances and who
the hell knows why, right?
You also hear opposites attract,
but they don't stay together.
The important thing is to find
someone similar to you or that
there's like one person that's right?
I mean, these are, if we really
think about it, crazy notions--
Paul Conti: Yes.
Andrew Huberman: --but they
drive a lot of what people think
about relationships, right?
Paul Conti: They drive angst.
Andrew Huberman: Right.
Paul Conti: They drive bad choices.
They drive situations that then create a
sense of guilt and shame and inadequacy.
We mislead ourselves by not going to
the basics of what is actually true.
Let me look at myself, make myself
as healthy as I can be, right?
Because if I'm healthy, I'll recognize a
lack of health in the other, s o it also
protects us against bad relationships.
And then if I'm going to make myself
healthy, which we're describing, how
that looks, wouldn't I want someone who
also wants to make themselves healthier?
At least if we're going to
ally, let's ally around making
both of ourselves healthier.
Andrew Huberman: Absolutely.
And we're going to go deeper into how
to look into the map of self and how
that relates to relationship, certainly
more as we go along this discussion.
You've mentioned several times,
however, about generative drive and
that it really is the definition
of like-minded in some sense.
And you also mentioned aggressive
drives and pleasure drives, themes
that we touched on again in episodes
one and two, but listening to those
episodes is certainly not necessary to
digest what we're talking about today.
Could you go a little bit deeper
into the generative drive,
flesh out for us what that is?
I think generative, I think
generator, I think energy.
I hear aggression or aggressive drive.
I think, as I think most people do,
friction, maybe even conflict, maybe
physical conflict, maybe verbal conflict.
But I know it's some of that
perhaps, but a whole lot more.
And then pleasure drive and pleasure.
Some people think bliss,
some people think delight.
Some people probably have all
sorts of specific things they
think of with respect to pleasure.
So if you could just flesh those out
for us a little bit more, because
I think those are going to serve as
cornerstones of today's discussion.
Paul Conti: Sure.
So drives, in this case the generative
drive, sort of exist within us.
And what they do is
they're defining potential.
So right now, one could argue, if
w e just pause for a couple of s
econds, we're not doing anything
generative in those seconds.
But then we resume doing something
that we believe is generative.
So at the time we're pausing, that's
when we can sort of look at that as a
drive within us to make new learning, to
understand things we didn't understand
before, to spread a sense of goodness.
So it resides in us in a way
that is determined by a whole
bunch of different factors.
Like everything else that's
determined within us, there's a
nature and a nurture component.
So some aspects of it are what are
the genetics that came down to us?
What are formative experiences?
But we can go in and alter that.
So if we see the drive as a set of
potentials, like in that moment, we pause.
There's a set of potentials within us,
like potential of where we can take our
thoughts, our actions, our reflections,
our decisions, that's the drive within us.
And it exists within us in a
way that we could localize now.
Like, if we think enough about, okay,
how much of a generative drive is there
in a person, how much is that person
looking to make a better life for
themselves or a better world around them?
And how do they feel about themselves
and their ability to do that?
How generative are they?
Or how shut down or
demoralized or envious?
So we can, in a sense, localize that.
And again, the localization has these
genetic and nurture components to it,
but we can then go and influence that.
And that's the importance.
If the drive is a set of potentials,
a set of possibilities, then that
drive is one and the same pervaded
with, however we want to describe
that, with the agency and gratitude,
because the agency and gratitude is
sort of the operative form of that.
That's the verb.
It's the drive, actually
driving something.
So if you have a strong generative
drive, then agency and gratitude
are leading the decisions.
The reflections are coming through
that, the aggression within us,
or again, that's the historical
word, but so we can say aggression,
assertion, proactiveness, right?
All of this inside of us and our
drive for pleasure, for gratification,
that all is, then it's in us, but
it's subserving the generative drive,
meaning the generative drive, that
set of potentials and possibilities
is dominant, which of course makes
sense with agency and gratitude, those
active verbs being what is most active.
And then we're also going to feel at
times, and hopefully at a lot of times,
that set of peacefulness, that sense of
contentment, the sense of delight, what
you're describing when you're doing the
podcast and you're in it and all these
good things are happening to you, right?
There's a strong generative drive in you.
That set of potentials are
being actualized through the
verbs of agency and gratitude.
Like you're doing it all right then,
and as you're doing it, you have
a sense of peace and contentment
as you're enacting all of it.
And then that makes you healthier.
It reinforces the generative drive.
It protects you against the next
sling or arrow of outrageous
fortune that will come your way.
You become more self knowledgeable,
more, you become stronger.
And ultimately, that's
what we're looking for.
That's the state of goodness.
And I believe that if you
look h istorically, what
is it that we're seeking?
We can put so many words to it, and
we're choosing to put these words to it.
I mean, I think that this is the
structure, because I think the
science, the history, the clinical
experience, the phenomenology,
I think it all tells us this.
We can put different words to it, but what
we're looking at when we're looking at
truth and how to get to the "happiness"
that people have sought through the
ages, I think we know enough now.
We've learned enough that we can say,
oh, this is what it looks like, and
it fits the arbiter of all truth,
which is, as you get further u p
the hierarchy, it gets simpler.
That's true about humans.
What's going on in my unconscious
is very, very complicated.
But if that's summing to, as we
get higher up to, I'm approaching
the world with a lot of agency and
gratitude, that's a lot simpler.
And that's what can be common among
us, which is why if my pillars are very
different from your pillars and what
we've struggled against, each is very
different, and what we may still have to
work against is very different, well, we
can be extremely compatible as friends,
because are we working on ourselves?
Are we fostering the generative drive so
we're coming at the world in that way?
And agency and gratitude, that's the
similarity between us that matters.
And ultimately, we're looking at the
potential that every moment we're building
the potential in us for what comes at the
next moment, which is why we're describing
the overlap, the point of commonality
that really matters, that matters.
We're putting a label to it.
We're saying it's the generative drive,
but i t is also that, okay, we both c ome
at the world through agency and gratitude.
If two people are assessing compatibility,
but if we're looking at something to nest
that under, and what seems most logical is
the set of potentials within us that we're
building and altering each moment, and
then as I alter it in this moment, it's
altered and then affects my next moment.
If I do something that's just kind of
thoughtless to somebody because I'm
in a bad mood, then what am I doing?
I'm projecting out my aggression.
I'm doing something that
basically makes me less than.
And then I'm going to feel
less in the next moment.
Whether that moment is about me or
is about someone else, the drives
are the potentials in us, but we are
actively working on them, determining
them, changing them each moment.
Andrew Huberman: I'm well on board the
idea that the typical pairings, let's
call them the idiosyncratic pairings of
musician with musician, in many cases, but
sometimes very verbal person with quieter
person, introvert with extrovert, or
introvert with introvert all of that takes
backseat or perhaps even back backseat.
Perhaps it even is out of the
vehicle compared to the critical
importance of generative drive.
Paul Conti: Right.
Andrew Huberman: When we think about
generative drives in individuals, you
beautifully described what a generative
drive is and how it shows up in
individuals when thinking about generative
drives in romantic relationships, however,
because generative drive can be expressed
to varying degrees, does one often see
that, or do you think that, a matching
of sort of levels of generative drives
is what fosters the best relationships?
In other words, let's say somebody
has a pretty high pleasure drive,
but not a very strong, aggressive,
also called, proactiveness drive.
And so maybe they watch a lot of
Netflix, like a lot of Netflix, but
they're not even the sort of person
that's really excited about the shows
and telling you about them, because
there's a version of watching a lot
of Netflix where the person is really
interested in learning and in knowing.
Maybe even they're thinking about
writing something, you know,
some poetry or book, or they're
bringing some of that to their life.
I mention it that way because
watching Netflix isn't bad, per se.
It's not anti-generative.
Paul Conti: Is it an
escape, or is it generative?
Is a person thinking about what they're
going to do, they're going to write
that book, or are they just trying
to numb out, and at the end of five
hours in front of the television, they
don't know what those five hours were?
There's no intrinsic value judgment
based upon a lot of things that
we make value judgments about.
You have to look at, who is the person?
What is the context?
Are they being generative or not?
Andrew Huberman: Yeah.
Some of the movies and shows that
I've watched in relationships became
the points of connection around, at
least to me, tremendously interesting
discussions on hikes that we took
the next day and reflections on our
own relationship and work and life.
And so I'm so glad that you point out that
there's nothing intrinsically valuable
or invaluable about something like
Netflix, or even intrinsically passive
about doing something like sitting around
or even reading books, for that matter.
There's a passive version of reading
great books also, people forget that.
It's hard to read a great
book and not learn something.
I guess that's why they're
called great books.
But there is a version of
that, and I know many people.
Paul Conti: People want
to possess the book.
I read the book and I'm going t o check
it off and I don't know what was in it.
Like people do that.
That is not generative.
Andrew Huberman: So should we consider
matching of level or expression of
generative drives as perhaps what we
are all seeking in seeking relationship?
And do you think that people tend to pair
up naturally, pair up with people that
have a similar level of generative drive?
Or if they don't, do you
think it leads to problems?
Paul Conti: Yeah, I think that by and
large people don't, that it's not the
thing that we're thinking about and
looking for in ourselves or others,
and I absolutely believe that it
makes problems and let's take a look--
Andrew Huberman: To not look.
It makes problems to not look.
Paul Conti: Right.
It makes sense.
The fact that we're not basing
it upon generative drive does
indeed, I think, make many, many
and in fact, countless problems.
And I would take as an example, think
about the idea of a trauma bond, right.
A trauma bond is not a bad thing.
That sounds like a strong statement,
because the way that I hear a
trauma bond used is it's a bad
thing, b ut it doesn't have to be.
So let's take a look at it.
Imagine that you have what
people call a trauma bond.
You have two people who will
make up a situation, right.
They're functioning in the world
around them, b ut they each have
had some very s ignificant trauma
that is creating issues in them.
So let's say they're avoidance issues.
A person doesn't feel safe or
comfortable in the world around them.
They get invited to places that
they'd like to go, but they don't go.
They want to go to the museum and see
something really new and cool there.
But there might be a crowd.
I mean, this happens.
And let's say you have two people
who both have this in them.
It could be because the trauma is similar.
The trauma could be night and day.
But they each have this in them.
They could bond around that trauma
in a way that worsens the trauma.
That's why people think
negatively of a trauma bond.
So if the case is that the trauma
bond is not a good thing f or these
two people, you say, why is that?
It's not because both of them have h
ad trauma and both of them are impacted
by trauma, and both of them a re
impacted by trauma in similar ways.
It's not that.
It's that the drives are not in a
healthy place and the gratification
of the generative drive and the
pleasure drives are not high enough.
So let's imagine the generative
drive could be relatively low in
each of these people in one or the
other, or they could have a naturally
high drive that's being thwarted.
So there's something that's out
of balance where the drive is,
the ability to express the drive.
Is there enough agency?
If there's not, like, let's say one
person is really, really shut down.
That person can't stand their job, right?
Okay.
Something is shutting that person down.
The generative drive wishes
for greater expression.
They go back and look at themselves.
You can bring that into line.
But something is out
of balance at the time.
The pleasure drive may be low or it may
be high, but it may not be gratified.
It may be that that person loves
museums and wants to go to the museum,
but can't find that gratification.
That's a possibility.
The aggression or assertion drive would
be on the low end, but it could be higher.
Maybe if that person felt safer, that
drive within them has a lot of latitude
in it, and maybe it could move higher.
But something is out of balance in
the drives and in their expression.
That's the problem.
Because let's look at the
other side, where a trauma
bond is a great thing, right?
So each of the people in the example
has trauma, and they recognize it in
themselves, and they understand how
it makes things harder for them, and
then they're communicating about how
it makes it hard in the other, right?
So maybe there's a lot of overlap
in social avoidance and sense of
vulnerability, but maybe there
are things that are different
in one person versus the other.
So then they can come together and
say, look, what's the goal of life?
I would like to be as
healthy a s I can be.
I'm working on myself.
You want to be as healthy as you can be?
We want to be as healthy as we can be.
And if we're healthy, we also
help e ach of us be healthy.
So maybe those two people, neither
of w hich they would ever go to the
m useum on their own, because the
trauma inside of them is at a point i
t hasn't been worked through, or it's
a t a place where they just simply feel
too vulnerable, but together they can
go to the museum, and then the bond
around trauma helps them be healthy.
The drives are in a better place
because they're able to recognize, hey,
there are things going on in me that
I'd like to be different and better,
and you recognize that, too, and we
can talk about it with one another.
Right?
So they're in a healthier place,
and then from that healthier
place, they build greater health.
Andrew Huberman: So much of what we
hear about in terms of friction points
in relationship centers around it seems
communication or lack of communication.
And as you're describing the role
of the generative drive in healthy
relationship, it seems to me that
it ties back in every way to agency
and gratitude and agency being such
a critical element of communication,
because wherever you've identified that,
okay, there's a potential problem here.
People with high generative drive in these
examples seem to be capable of, like,
self inquiry, asking the other person
questions that bring them closer together
and to a deeper understanding of the self.
I raise this because one thing that's
often overheard, or that I've overheard,
I of course have siblings and friends,
and I'll place this in the way that I've
most typically heard it, but I'm sure it
exists in other ways too, which is the
conversation in my head is one where a
woman is saying they're with somebody or
dating somebody, and he's so clueless.
I wish that he would just do this thing.
Sometimes these are acts of chivalry,
like, maybe it's flowers or vacations, but
more often than not, it's a request or a
complaint about a lack of proactiveness.
This is also what ratchets up to
these very pan statements that you
hear, like, oh, there's no real men
these days, or like, there are no
real men left, or this kind of thing.
You also hear it in the reverse, right?
You hear men making pan
statements about women.
And here we're doing this in the
context of heterosexual pairings.
Paul Conti: But of course it
could all work just as well.
Andrew Huberman: It could all work in
the context of homosexual pairings too.
So you hear those sorts of things, and
it sounds like a lack of communication.
Okay, maybe one person needs to be better
at asking for their needs to be met.
Maybe the other person needs
to develop more of an awareness
of what the other person needs.
Of course, we all seem to kind of
intrinsically wish that things would
just happen for us without the need
to request them or ask for them.
But I'm realizing again that all of
that is distracting commotion, because
that's not really what's going on.
What's really going on, it seems, is
that the engine behind communication, the
engine behind curiosity, a desire to learn
and know and create something from that
learning and knowing in the relationship,
the generative drive, is really what's
the issue, or the lack of generative
drive in any of those conversations.
It seems one could circle back to that and
go, okay, well, someone's not asking the
right questions and therefore not doing
the right things because they don't either
have a sense of agency, or they don't have
gratitude for the situation they're in,
including their own ability to do that.
Right?
So when you hear people aren't showing
up for the relationship, they're not
showing up, or she's not showing up.
Or again, let's make the pan statement
go in the other direction, that
somebody just wants a lot of attention.
They just need an excess amount
of attention, won't let me do
my own thing, but also want
me to work and be successful.
Again, these are stereotypes, but
all of that seems very distracting.
However, all of it seems far simpler
if we push it through this filter
of generative drives and whether
or not it's being expressed.
Paul Conti: Yes.
I think maybe the best example of t
his, because it's so highly charged,
is, i magine that the pleasure drive is
through the lens of sex and sexuality.
So imagine that people are in a pairing,
they're in a relationship, regardless
of h ow they got there, w e're taking...
people are in a relationship.
And one h as say, a sex drive, which means
a n interest in sex and maybe proclivities
for diversity of sexual experience.
Let's say if we just for sake of
this example, we put on a one to
10 scale, that person is a two.
Okay, now let's say the other
person in the relationship--
Andrew Huberman: 10 being the greatest?
Paul Conti: Yeah, sorry.
10 being the greatest.
That person is a two.
Now let's say the partner is an eight.
Okay, so there's a big mismatch there,
you think, how does that normally go?
The two stays a two, the eight stays
an eight, and things don't go well.
Andrew Huberman: Right.
Paul Conti: It creates
friction in the relationship.
At a minimum, it blows
the relationship apart.
At a maximum, the person who's
a two feels inadequate often.
I mean, it's not always right,
but this is how this often goes.
Person who's a two feels inadequate
because the person who's an eight
wants either more or different and
the person who's a two doesn't.
Now that person feels bad, and they may
feel bad about themselves or resentful
of the person with a higher sex drive.
The person on the higher level
feels now resentful of the
person at the lower level.
Or maybe they feel like there's something
wrong with them because their sex drive
i s too high, or they have an i nterest
that the other person doesn't have.
And now they start labeling themselves.
This happens all the time and it
doesn't change most of the time.
And the problems are enormous.
Okay, let's see.
How would that look with really
high generative drives and
therefore the ability to think
about self, to think about others,
and to think about the "us" of the
situation, t he two people together.
So they would be able to talk
about it in ways that wouldn't be
faulting of the other and would
acknowledge what's inside of them.
Like, the person with the lower drive
could say things like, it doesn't
strike me as more interesting.
I don't think about it more.
They could talk about all of that.
The person who wishes more
or wishes different could
talk about that too, right.
And could talk about what they feel
inside, if there's a frustration of that.
Just like the person with the lower
sex drive could talk about how
frustrating i t feels to feel pressured.
Right?
So what are they developing?
They're mentalizing.
They're thinking about each other's
emotional states, and they're coming at
each other through agency and gratitude.
Like, I'm so grateful for you.
Remember, see, the example is these
people are partners and they're
happy with their partnership.
Like, oh, my God, I'm
so grateful I found you.
They would each feel that way.
I'm so grateful you're in my life.
Like, this happens too, right?
And then from that lens, the two
isn't going to become an eight.
The eight isn't going to become a two.
But in general, in situations
like this, there can be
somewhere in the middle, right?
Let's say the two says,
like, okay, you know what?
I can get out of my
comfort zone a little bit.
Why don't most people try that?
Because they feel embarrassed,
they feel self conscious.
They don't want to try
new things or try more.
People get closed down because
there's such shame around sexuality.
You could take people on any spectrum
of sexuality and you will find shame
not in every person, but across
whatever population we're looking at,
because it's so emotionally charged.
So let's say in a loving, caring
relationship, you're like, that
person feels the freedom inside.
Say, you know what?
Maybe I could enjoy sex a
little more, a little more
often, a little more innovative.
That person thinks about it like somebody
who's at a two can then move t hat to
a different place a little b it more,
or maybe even a lot more, depending.
And then the person who's at the
h igher level, the eight doesn't
need another eight in order to stay
in the relationship, but something
maybe more than a two, right?
And then let's say they come into
the middle, and then the person who's
an eight realizes like, look, I love
you and you love me and you're out of
your comfort zone in order to do this.
And wow, a nd it's like
more fun for both of us.
So you know what?
It's okay.
My higher sex drive, I'll deal with that.
That maybe just making it up, l ike, I
would like to do it t hree times a week.
We're doing it, two.
Okay, you know what?
That's fine.
Both sides can live with it.
But it is not threadbear.
It's not like, well,
they can live with it.
It's like, no.
Number one, they can live with it.
Number two, it's better.
It's better, right?
The two at one point was
thinking, hey, anything more
than a two is, I can't do that.
They shut down.
The eight doesn't want
anything less than an eight.
Now they're in the middle and
their relationship is closer.
That's real.
That happens.
What is it relying upon?
It's relying upon the generative
drive to h ave the openness,
the ability to communicate.
Maybe the person who's an eight,
say, has a sexual proclivity
they're embarrassed about.
That happens all the time, too.
But in the sense of acceptance of self
and the belief in the strength of the
relationship and the acceptance of t
he other, people can broach things.
Most people who feel like, oh,
I c ould never broach that.
It's not something bizarre or dangerous.
It's not something that in a relationship
that's defined by the generative drive,
the o ther person is likely to reject.
So let's define our relationships
through the g enerative drive,
and let's cultivate in self a nd
others the most generative drive.
If somehow, let's say, person A and
p erson B here, because it doesn't
matter who's the eight and who's
the two, h as cultivated more of a
generative drive, then maybe that person
could give more t o the other before
that person can give back to them.
We have these, I think, just completely
nonsensical ideas about mutuality.
The idea that even in a situation that's
supposed to be defined by love, a nd
friendship is a form of love, right?
So friendship, a collaborative endeavor,
they have some affection in them, right?
Friendship can have love and often does.
And let's say the love of
romance, that there's supposed
to be some equality, right?
The idea that, well, if I'm going t
o give something, I want you to give
something, too, it is not good if one
person is always doing the giving.
Things are out of balance, but it
is very healthy to be able to s ay,
if I can give something and y ou're
not in a place to give something.
Let me just give something to you.
People don't always, or maybe don't often
depend on how we want to look at it,
give to others with a sense of freedom.
And you don't owe me anything either.
Why?
Because it comes from love.
It comes from the abundance, the excess of
goodness in me coming through the agency
that I feel, the gratitude that I feel.
And then what's more likely, you're much
more likely the other person, to sort of
feel like, hey, I can go a little more.
You feel stronger, you feel empowered
making someone feel worse or saying,
you know what, I can give you something,
but you owe me something back.
Even if that's tacit, I
can give you this now.
But you kind of know that the other
person is going to end up doing the
laundry for two months or something
like that, this is not okay.
Why don't I just give something?
You're giving goodness, and then the
other person actually gets the goodness,
and they're more likely to find it within
themselves to then come a little out of
their comfort zone, develop, move their
generative drive a little bit forward.
Gifts given to others with no expectation
of return are gifts of abundance.
They're gifts that arise from
the generative d rive, and
they make us more generative.
Think about the opposite.
W hat often happens, each person
makes the other feel guilty, right?
Oh, this person wants you, wants so much.
And look, there you are again.
Like, people feel terrible
about that, or t he're you don't
want any sex, or this or that.
The other person feels terrible.
That's why the two stays the two
and the eight stays the eight.
But it doesn't have to be that way, a
nd it's also not that if both end up
in the middle, say both a re a five,
that that's some compromised position.
That implies less.
No, that's the compromised
position that makes more.
Andrew Huberman: I'd like to take
a brief break and acknowledge
our sponsor, Eight Sleep.
Eight Sleep makes smart mattress
covers with cooling, heating
and sleep tracking capacity.
I've spoken many times before on this
podcast and elsewhere about the fact
that getting a quality night's sleep on a
regular basis is the foundation of mental
health, physical health, and performance.
When we're sleeping well,
everything goes better.
And when we are not sleeping well
or enough, everything in terms of
mental health, physical health, and
performance gets far worse very quickly.
One of the key things to getting a
great night's sleep is to control the
temperature of your sleeping environment.
And that's because in order to
fall and stay deeply asleep, you
need your core body temperature to
drop by about one to three degrees.
And in order to wake up feeling refreshed,
you need your core body temperature to
increase by about one to three degrees.
That all becomes very easy when using
an Eight Sleep mattress cover because
it allows you to program the temperature
of your sleeping environment at the
beginning, middle, and towards the
end of your night when you wake up.
I started sleeping on an Eight Sleep
mattress cover over two years ago, and
it immediately and persistently improved
the quality and depth of my sleep.
And as a consequence, I wake
up feeling far more refreshed.
I have enhanced mood, focus and
alertness throughout the day.
If you'd like to try Eight Slee p, you
can go to eightsleep.com/huberman to
save up to $150 off their Pod 3 Cover.
Eight Sleep currently ships
in the USA, Canada, UK, select
countries in the EU and Australia.
Again, that's eightsleep.com/huberman
.
Based on my understanding of the
generative drive, the aggressive also,
we're calling it proactiveness drive, and
the pleasure drive, and the importance
of the generative drive being greater
than the aggressive or pleasure drives,
I can also see the potential problem of
having, like, two eights along the sexual
desire scale, or two nines, or two tens.
And actually, I've observed
a lot of examples of this.
For instance, if there are, let's say,
two nines, put both people nine out of
10 on the joy and sort of proclivity
for sex, adventurous sex, etc., they're
very high on the pleasure scale, perhaps
even so much so that they don't pay
attention to, or one person doesn't
pay attention to the critical need for
points of compatibility to be met, like
the desire to someday have a family.
I've known couples like this.
They're together for a long time.
They seem to really enjoy one another.
I know nothing of their sex lives, but
there just seems to be a very strong
attachment around certain forms of
pleasure that they both enjoy engaging in.
So this could be activities or travel.
I mean, here we're saying nine
out of 10 on the sex scale.
But in many of those cases, there's one
person saying, but I want to have a family
someday, and they're just not into that.
Or perhaps even like, but
he won't leave his wife.
They're involved in something
that feels really good.
They're matching along some pleasure
drive, but completely overlooking the
larger goals of one or both people.
Right here I pointed to an instance of
infidelity that's its own issues with
morals, etc., but you see this a lot.
People really orienting towards what
feels good and who feels good to be with.
And that, of course, is healthy,
but that's not the entire picture.
So would you say that what I'm describing
is an example of where the pleasure
drive has overcome the generative drive?
Because in the case of somebody wanting
a family and the other person already
having one and being unwilling to leave
that one or the other person not wanting
a family, that the generative drive of
the person who wants a family is not
being respected or it's being undermined
by this excess desire for pleasure.
Like they're just drawn into the
moment and the amazing weekends,
but this person's incredible
and they're charismatic.
And I can't tell you how many times
I've had friends say that they admire
the person they're with, but they know
the relationship can't work because
of all these other underlying issues.
Paul Conti: Right.
It's interesting.
We both overestimate and
underestimate what, say, love can do.
Right?
People say, oh, love can do anything.
No, if I spill that glass, love's not
going to put the water back in it.
If I must live in North America a nd
my partner must live in South America,
we're not going to be okay, r ight?
So we say these things
in a very wishful way.
Love will overcome everything.
It doesn't overcome that, o r maybe
it does in the right circumstances.
So think about if the generative
drive i s very high in both people,
s o both people have, say, a strong
n eed to live in a certain place, t
hey can find a compromise position.
Maybe they live half the year in North
America and half in South America.
But why?
Because in that situation, the
love between them, which is the
generative drive in the relationship.
So what does that mean?
The first person has to have a strong
generative drive, be healthy, understand
that even though I n eed to live in North
America, does it actually mean that?
That I really need to
live in North America?
I have to be able to see beyond
myself, a nd what does that mean to
the p erson I love who needs to live
o n the other side of the world?
If the other person can do that
t oo, then in the relationship,
which is a new entity, i t emerges
from one person and the other.
You can know everything about one
person, everything about the other.
You don't know about the
two of them together.
So the two of them together are an "us".
And if that us has a strong generative
drive, which it can If each person
has a strong generative drive, they
can bring to the state of emergence
of the us the generative drive.
And we're talking about a relationship,
so say the love between them
and they can find a way through.
So the idea that love cures
all things, we have to define,
what does that actually mean?
It doesn't mean we have a lot
of pleasure together, right?
Or we like a lot of the same things.
That's not what that means, a nd people
can very much love one another but not be
aware of the limitations inside of them.
Because maybe there are other things going
on in them, like, say, childhood trauma.
They love one another, but they can't
g et out of their comfort zone enough.
So the point is, if we make ourselves
as healthy as we can be a nd then two
selves come together that a re making
themselves as healthy as they c an be,
then the us between them really can fit
that definition of love and do anything.
But we have to define that in the
right way, in a way that honors
the truth, which, again, is not
a higher degree of complexity.
It's actually more simple.
Andrew Huberman: So you gave an
example of a romantic relationship
where one person has a strong sex
drive and the other a weaker drive.
And then we talked about an example where
both people have an essentially high sex
drive and where that could potentially be
beneficial, assuming that the generative
drive is also high in both of them.
And we also explored a little bit of
how it can be bad for relationship
if it exceeds the generative drive.
What about the aggressive
proactiveness drive?
How does that show up
in romantic pairings?
If one person has a high proactiveness,
aka aggressive drive, and the other
person does not, what does that look like?
Do you see that often in
your clinical practice?
Paul Conti: Sure.
If this makes sense, maybe we look
a t that example of the person
who's a two and the person who's an
eight on the sex drive scale, right?
You'd say, okay, the person who's
a t wo, who's trying to raise that
right, has a strong generative drive.
What does that mean?
The person thinks, you know what?
I think I can do this.
I can set myself about this.
I see it will make my relationship
better, I'm going to give it a try.
That's a generative drive in
action, the pleasure drive.
The person may look at that and say, look,
maybe this can be more fun for me, right?
It hasn't been that fun for me.
If I have a low pleasure drive,
could I start enjoying this more?
And then maybe that moves up, right?
Or maybe I have a higher pleasure drive,
but it's not been gratified because I
haven't been able to be open and honest.
Let me see if I can make that better.
Then what's active, what the person is d
oing, is then going to be the aggressive
or assertive, proactive to that drive
and going to the potential in that
drive and mining some of what's in it.
Like, yeah, how am I going to do that?
I'm going to bring myself to bear,
a nd that's not an easy thing.
It's not like that person then all of
a sudden decides to be more sexual.
There has to be a lot of communication
between the two people, a lot of
discussion of what setting might be best
for that, what helps the person feel
understood or feel more comfortable.
There's a lot then, to do there.
And the person may even need to
g o back to the pillars because
the p erson may feel like, whoa,
I don't think I can do that.
And then it is...
that's not good.
I want to do that.
What is it that I can't do?
There's a realization there.
And then maybe the person who's an eight
because they're so well connected gets it.
Okay.
You can't do that.
Let me support you in whatever way
while you're figuring that out.
Because they're both generative,
they want to figure that out.
Andrew Huberman: Sorry to interrupt.
When you say, go back to the pillars,
you mean go back to exploring
the structure of themselves and
their function of themselves--
Paul Conti: Yes.
Andrew Huberman: --so that they can, for
instance, get some insight into what sorts
of defense mechanisms might be in place--
Paul Conti: Right.
Andrew Huberman: --what they're paying
attention to or their behaviors,
like maybe even health related
behaviors that could be impacting
their sex drive, but maybe even
things that reside at a deeper level.
The unconscious mind, talking to somebody
till they make a connection around shame
or some story that they've integrated into
their thinking at a subconscious level.
Paul Conti: Right.
Just an example that I see a l ot is
avoidance, where, again, not always,
but let's say the person who's the
two on the sex drive scale who f inds
like, I can't do it, r ight, wow,
I just can't bring myself to do it.
And then they go back and they explore.
This happens a lot
where there's avoidance.
And then we get curious about the
avoidance because the person's
like, there's something that
just, I don't want to do that.
So there's avoidance.
We identify avoidance.
We also identify that it's not healthy,
b ecause the person does actually
want to do that because it's good
for the relationship and it could be
good for them, too, a nd then maybe
we start looking at u nconscious
mind, right, or conscious mind.
And maybe we don't find
it, because it's easy.
Now, if I said, oh, there was a major
trauma that the person hasn't processed.
Sometimes it's that, but a
lot of times it's not that.
Maybe that person just never learned
to feel comfortable with sexuality.
Or maybe the way that they experience
o r are attracted to sexuality
was disparaged or denigrated.
Or they had some bad feeling
about it because the society
and the culture told them that.
Or maybe they had a couple
of bad experiences where they
were treated in a certain way.
And then it's like, okay, that
person comes by that honestly,
there's not a major trauma there.
In fact, unfortunately, there's a trauma
that's almost predictable from the
way our society has been structured.
So person can go, look at that.
I'm like, right, I never
learned how t o do this or how
to be comfortable with this.
Or you know what I learned that
I'm not good at it, or I learned
that no one will enjoy it with me.
But that's not true.
These are situations not on the
side o f a loving relationship.
Now t hat person is able to bring that
knowledge to bear, whether it came from t
he unconscious mind or the conscious mind.
And then that's how you work
to start shifting things.
Like, that was then, this is now.
It is not then.
when, say, the person, say in
high s chool, had a sexuality that
others didn't a pprove of and made
them feel bad, well, guess what?
It's not then.
And that's unfortunate.
It's wrong.
It's unjust.
We're going to honor and
validate all that that is.
But we're also going to look at that.
That was then, this is now.
And you get to behave differently now.
You're an adult now, and adults
get to choose their relationships,
and you chose a good relationship.
So this is the kind of thing that can
get that person to the p oint where
they can go back up through now.
What happens at the end of it?
The geyser is stronger.
There's more agency, there's
more of a sense of gratitude.
Why?
Because the person can attach themselves
more to, I'm so lucky to have this person,
as opposed to, damn it, I wish that person
didn't have a higher sex drive, right?
And they feel better about themselves
instead o f, what's wrong with me
that I d on't have a higher sex drive?
Or I said they wish the other person
had a lower sex drive or wish they had
a higher sex drive that's not grateful.
Like I'm grateful I am who I a m and
that I have any sex drive at all.
And I'm grateful for this other person.
Now, through that, that change, they can
go back and better access the assertion,
t he proactive drive, the aggressive
drive, whatever w e want to call it,
because they've taken away, they've gone
and worked through the barrier to it.
Then they're able to be a little m
ore out of their comfort zone, and the
other person meets them there, right?
And they start having this healthy thing
b etween them where the us that is them,
the love between them, gets better, right?
And then where do they find themselves?
That's how they get to the five,
which is not a compromise between
eight a nd two that satisfies neither.
It is a compromise between eight
and t wo that is way better for
both and for the relationship.
Andrew Huberman: I'm curious about
common pairings that you observe in
the clinical setting, and not to focus
on the bad, but if there are common
pairings that rarely lead to a good
outcome, I think it's worth us learning
about those, simply because they're
common and they lead to a bad outcome.
And a discussion of this sort could
potentially help people avoid such
pairings, or at least recognize
that they're in such pairings.
And I realize, of course, because
of the way that we're framing things
during this series, that anytime we
talk about a pairing, we're really
talking about two maps coming together,
forming a new and somewhat independent
map that represents the relationship.
I have to assume that many people in
the world have maps that are very,
very healthy, and they're probably
even those rare individuals that don't
need to go into those cupboards that
reside within structure of self and
function of self and do any work.
But for those of you that are just
listening and not watching this,
I'm sort of smiling as I'm saying
that, because I don't actually
believe any such person exists.
I think all of us, even the healthiest
among us, could be even healthier
and express more generative drive and
more positivity for ourselves and for
the world were we to do that work.
Paul Conti: Yes.
Absolutely.
Andrew Huberman: So it's a lifelong--
Paul Conti: There's no endpoint to that.
That's beautiful.
We can do that forever
as long as we're here.
Andrew Huberman: And you
should, I do believe.
Which is one of the reasons
for having this discussion.
Exactly.
Nonetheless, I have to imagine that
there are also a lot of people out
there, perhaps most people, who
still have a lot of work to do.
And those words, a lot, perhaps,
are in bold faced capital
underlined, highlighted letters.
And as a consequence, we see relationships
in the world that are not healthy.
What are some of those
common unhealthy pairings?
I think it's worth spending at
least a little bit of time on this.
Paul Conti: Yeah, sure.
As we talk about this, I think that we
should make a sort of somewhat simplified
but hopefully helpful distinction.
So there are people who are coming a t
coupling from primarily health, right?
And again, this isn't to criticize
people who aren't coming at
it from primarily health.
We all want to get to where
we're coming at anything and
everything from primarily health.
And there a lot of the problems are
those simple things like, wow, I
can't believe it didn't work out.
I play the trumpet and
he plays the clarinet.
It's like, no, that wasn't
a real set of factors.
That's why it didn't work out.
It's more in that realm.
It's not always just that, but that
k ind of stuff is a big factor.
When we look in the other realm, where
there are significantly problematic
mental health issues, which people
come by honestly but need to face if
life is going to get better, there
are two common paradigms there.
Now, again, there are way more than
t wo ways this can happen, but I'm
going to highlight two that we see
a lot and maybe more than anything
else in the clinical setting.
So the first gets called
repetition compulsion.
But I want to be very clear, I do
not believe that there is any such
thing as a repetition compulsion.
A compulsion is something
that one cannot control.
What's going on inside the person is
very, very complicated when they're making
decisions that lead to repeating a cycle.
And those are things that can change
and do not have to be compulsive.
So people are often struck by why a person
is in the same bad relationship, seemingly
that they have always been in, but with
a different name on the other person.
I mean, people will say this like i t's
that person's fourth abusive relationship
in a row, and it seems to be, it's just
the same person with a different name.
People say that a lot.
They say that about themselves,
they say that about others,
and it's very, very baffling.
I mean, people have often been in my
office very upset about that, like
realizing they're repeating and they
don't know and it's frightening.
And you can get a lot of fear
and vulnerability from that.
But there's a way of understanding it
that, because the limbic system, the
emotional parts of our minds don't
care about the clock and the calendar.
So trauma impacts, it impacts
the whole brain, but trauma
impacts the limbic system.
It creates strong negative emotion that
then stays with us regardless of time.
It doesn't care about time.
So imagine now a person gets in a
relationship and the relationship
starts to become abusive.
I mean, it's easy to say that and
then move on to something else.
What's that like for that person?
What does that feel like when
that person, who they may have
seen as a protector, a friend, is
now cursing at them, denigrating
them, pushing them, hitting them?
I mean, it's terrifying.
It's horrible, right?
So it is a deep impact, a t
raumatic impact on the person.
And a lot of the time, most of the time,
like all trauma, it triggers shame.
So trauma triggers shame in us.
If the trauma is strong enough, it changes
us as we move forward in the world.
And then we are different
in a way that makes the past
very immediate in the present.
So what the person then is trying to
do, and there's been a lot of thought
about this over the years in the
fields, trying to understand this,
and I think in many ways doing a good
job of understanding this, that the
"repetition compulsion" is the drive,
and I don't mean drive like we're saying.
There's a push inside the person to
t ry and make that right with the i
dea that if that person can be in that
situation again, and I don't mean in
the exact situation when someone raises
a hand to them, but they can navigate
a relationship because they thought
it was a good idea the first time.
So they don't want to feel
like that was a very bad idea.
So I'm going to make it right, a nd
then I'm going to be okay and I'm
going to be whole because the person
is driven by fear and v ulnerability
and the shame of the trauma.
So then they're trying to make it
right because the limbic system doesn't
care about the clock or the calendar.
If you can make it right now.
You make it right in the past, b ecause
that system doesn't care about the past.
It's driven by trauma, s o then
the person's trying to figure
out something that is different.
They're trying to choose that person,
behave in the relationship, they're trying
to make t hings different, but they've
selected for a d ramatically high pretest
probability of the same t hing happening
again, which is why if I could count the
number of times t hat someone has said
to me, oh, you're not going to help me,
especially a t the beginning of therapy.
There's no way you can help me.
Five relationships were totally terrible.
There's no way.
There's no hope, right?
People have said that to me so many times.
The last three, the last
five, the last nine.
And I will say back, if you t ell me
seven different stories of relationships
with seven pretty different people,
several different relationships as
they evolved, and the same really
bad outcome, I'll agree with you,
but you're not going to tell me that.
And that's why there's hope.
And no one has ever told me s even
different stories where I feel like,
wow, you just can't do it, right?
No.
And again, even if there were seven,
I'm saying things for exaggeration.
But there aren't.
What is it?
It's the same thing seven times.
That's what it is.
Because the person is repeating.
And if they can understand the what
and the why, why are they selecting?
How are they selecting someone?
What's going on inside of them?
We go back to the structure
of self, the function of self.
We address what is there then
that absolutely can change.
And then what we will talk about
is that person then goes out
to find another relationship.
Even if they said they
never, never would again.
Like now they're making the
decision to go out, as to say, what
relationship a re you looking for?
Your second.
You're the first one seven times.
No harm, no foul.
But you can navigate the second
because they're in a different place.
They're coming through
agency and gratitude instead
of denigrating themselves.
If you're what's wrong with me, what's
wrong with everybody else, I'm here.
Even though some bad things
have happened to me, look at
what I can bring myself to bear.
I can go out there and try and find
someone I can see with clear vision now.
There's agency, there's gratitude,
and then that p erson can go
out and find relationship number
two that's a really good one.
Andrew Huberman: In the example you gave,
it's very powerful and also very extreme.
An abusive relationship where someone
is sadly getting hit or screamed at.
Oftentimes, it seems people end up in
repeated unsuccessful pairings, meaning
unhappy pairings of maybe someone who's
very strongly assertive, maybe we would
say has a strong aggressive drive.
Some people might even
call them a narcissist.
That phrase is thrown
around a lot these days.
I mean, narcissists,
gaslighting, like projection.
These phrases are thrown around all
the time, I think, with frankly,
very little understanding of what
they actually mean, unless they're
coming from a qualified clinician.
Is it the case that somewhat
passive or submissive people
are drawn to narcissists?
Are narcissists drawn
to submissive people?
I think these questions ring
in a lot of people's minds.
Paul Conti: If I could clarify
something that I think I maybe
could have said in a clearer way.
You pointed out that the example
I gave was a very strong one
or an extreme one, right?
So as a physician, I think I
naturally gravitate to the extreme
circumstances because they're the
ones that bring the greatest risk.
But we are talking to people in those
settings, but most people are not
in those extreme settings, but that
extreme serves as a model for how
things that are less extreme can happen.
So when I think, we're sitting here
talking to everyone across the spectrum,
and most relationships that are not
going well, thank goodness, are not
going to be that extreme, or the repeated
patterns aren't going to be that extreme.
But it's just as important to pay
attention to a pattern where one person
really is sort of more deferential than
they would like to be to the other,
than is comfortable to them, and they're
seeking someone, ultimately, who's just
a little bit more assertive, and that's
not s ome disaster, but it cannot go well
over time, where that person slowly gives
up, say, more and more of themselves.
And there can be that repeated pattern.
You hear people say, yeah, it was
pretty good or pretty equal at the
beginning, but then I just had l ess and
less of a say, or t hen more and more.
I just became the whole relationship.
So it's no less important
when it's less dramatic.
Because the relationship still goes in
a wrong way when it's more dramatic.
There's more risk, of course, but most
p eople are going to be in the less
dramatic but super important category.
And I think it's important
to point that out, too.
Andrew Huberman: How much of what we're
talking about is nested on people's deep,
perhaps understandable desire to just make
sure that the other person doesn't leave?
I can't tell you how many times I've heard
about or observed relationships that from
the outside that seemed really unhealthy.
But it also occurred to me that people
are doing things on both sides of
the relationship that ensure that
the other person doesn't leave.
So I'm not talking about a physical
trapping of someone in the environment.
I'm actually talking about the opposite.
I'm talking about somebody going against
their better judgment and doing things
for the other person or against themselves
or both, perhaps even in the context
of what looks like healthy family, like
doing an excessive amount of raising
of children or excessive amount of work
to support the family, simply to ensure
that the other person doesn't leave.
Paul Conti: Right.
Here, again, we can look
across the spectrum.
So before this, you had talked
about relationships that can be very
unhealthy, like a narcissistic person.
And how can those relationships develop?
It's important that we touch on
that in the context of this because
that's sort of the extreme example.
So people who are narcissistic, meaning
a narcissistic character structure.
Now we're getting into the realm of
significant psychiatric problems.
And people who are
narcissistic are exploitative.
They're a bottomless pit of
need arising from vulnerability,
and yes, they can be helped.
And if someone out there thinks I'm
narcissistic, then not trying to
be negative or mean like you can
get help and you can be better.
That's the whole point of what
you and I are talking about here.
So people can change, but someone
who's coming at the world through a
narcissistic character structure is
exploitive of the other and then can
say, survey a room and find that person
who's had trauma such that that person
is going to be desperate not to leave a
relationship, and then they can exploit
that person and often behave in awful
ways and the other person won't leave.
Now I'm giving an example.
It's not the case that
way every single time.
But that's the dominant picture.
If you have a narcissistic person and who
is that person more likely to pair with,
and then you sense the vulnerability, the
desire for the other person not to leave,
and that person would have to have then
significant problems in themselves, like
potentially, instead of a pathological
level of narcissism, a pathological
level of dependence, for example.
So we're in the realm
then, of real problems.
And again, real problems can be treated
and real problems can be improved,
and that's why we have clinical care,
but it can also serve as a model for
seeing the ways that are less dramatic.
So there are many people who,
through the desire for the other
person not to leave, and we could
call that attachment insecurity.
And maybe if we leave away the stereotype
version of it, the person doesn't feel
securely attached to the other person.
And somewhere inside of them, they've
learned that if they're more pleasing, if
they give up little parts of themselves,
that person won't leave, right?
It might be because that's why their
m other didn't leave their father,
when they think about it, it might
be that's why their father left
their mother, because their mother
wouldn't do that, whatever it may be.
Or it may be their own prior
life experience or who knows,
something they read but forgot?
I mean, usually it's something
more salient, not always, but
they've internalized something that
leads to a compromise of the self.
Now, again, that's not what
attachment insecurity is.
Attachment insecurity is just feeling
some insecurity about the attachment.
So, for example, I feel attachment
insecurity about just about everything.
I've had the experience of sudden,
very painful losses happening,
so I have attachment insecurity
in the sense that I'm worried.
I get anxious about people going
away, and I can want to over control,
but I recognize this inside myself.
I try and do my best to say, look, I
don't want that to make me unhealthy.
I want to recognize it.
I want to find some happy medium
where I honor that in me, but don't
get carried away with it to the point
where I try and over control and then
I push my relationships away, right?
So I say that because there's such
a contrast between that kind of
attachment insecurity, which can
involve over control, and the kind
of attachment insecurity that can
involve compromise of the self.
And we want to be very, very careful.
We want to be careful.
What is a trauma bond
and what does it mean?
We want to be careful.
What is attachment insecurity
and what does it mean?
A certain kind of attachment
insecurity can lead a person to make
progressive compromises of self that
are not good and healthy for them.
Andrew Huberman: I'm curious about some
of these unhealthy relationships from
the other side, meaning from the side of
the person who is, let's hope not, but
in some cases exploited or who's being
taken advantage of, or in this scenario
of a narcissistic person or an abusive
person is the one who's taking the abuse.
Often, it seems the victim in
that scenario will be truly
stuck in that situation.
They can't leave for financial reasons
or kids or their own internal workings.
Their psychological machinery has
them locked into that in some way.
And it's that locked in by psychological
machinery that I'm interested in.
And I think a lot of people are
interested in, because from the
outside we just look at that and
say, why doesn't the person leave?
Why don't they just leave?
But clearly there's something about
that "situation" that works for them.
And by works for them, I don't mean
that it's adaptive, clearly it's
maladaptive, but that works for them.
The possibility I raised earlier
perhaps is relevant here.
Maybe it works for them because they know
that the narcissist gets some sort of
internal reward for engaging in this kind
of dynamic and therefore won't leave.
And the other person not leaving is of
more value to them than feeling safe.
Even so, it's trading one
form of safety for another.
Or perhaps the victim, as we're calling
them in this scenario, is somebody
who feels a great sense of reward by
serving somebody more powerful than them.
This raises all sorts of interesting
questions, perhaps about power
dynamics as well, which I
certainly have questions about.
But what are some examples of the internal
workings of such a person that reside
within those bins of structure of self or
function of self that would put someone
into that sort of situation and lead
them to stay in that kind of situation?
Paul Conti: Well, any situation like
that, if it's, as you say, working for a
person, which at times we see that from
t he outside because things continue
to go along and things continue to go
forward, b ut that only works for someone
if t hey don't have the understanding,
the empowerment, t hat we would wish
for anyone and everyone to have.
So what is going on inside leads that
person to feel a sense of an inability
to change, whether they can't see their
way out of it or they kind of could, but
could never navigate to it, and there's
a problem there if that's working for
someone, b ecause we're talking about
something that's exploitive, right?
That's abusive regardless
of how it's abusive.
And I think, I believe, that can
only happen in the context of being
demoralized or the circumstances
of being so disempowered.
If someone just can't go 10 feet
from home, like there are situations
of outrageous amounts of oppression
of a person where the person
just cannot choose differently.
And there are situations where we,
as stewards of all of us, where
the government may intervene, for
example, ideally, right, as someone
would come in and help that person.
But barring that kind of outlier, a
person would only be in that situation
in the context of being demoralized.
And that demoralization would come
from too low a drive for assertion,
being proactive aggression, right?
That that drive, its
realization, is too low.
And if we give people the understanding
and we give them the help, the means, they
don't have to stay in abusive situations.
Like we see this, in situations where our
society will intervene or someone helpful
will intervene, some person or entity
will intervene and help a person, help
that person to understand what's going on
inside of them, that leads them to feel
that things can't be better, they can't
do better, or that they're not worth
better, or whatever that may be, and help
them to find the empowerment, to then
navigate themselves out of the situation.
And here again, I think it's
not just agency, but it's
agency plus gratitude, right?
Including gratitude for having a
self that could leave a situation.
When people are in situations like that,
we talk about people as beaten down.
It's a way to kind of capture what I think
that feels like and how much suffering
there is in those situations to be in
that place and to not have the agency
to get out of it, then the person is not
feeling a sense of gratitude for self.
They feel so bad about self that
there's nothing to be grateful for.
And there is so much to be grateful for.
We could go through any person in a
situation like that, and we could list
wonderful things about that person,
adaptive things about that person, kind
things about that person, diligent things.
There are things like
that in every person.
But if the person can't see that, they
can't attach to that, they can't have the
agency and gratitude, then they stay in
a situation that is really defined by the
agency and gratitude, and therefore that
aggressive assertion, proactive drive
being expressed at such a low level.
Andrew Huberman: I can see how a healthy
relationship could exist in relative
isolation, not complete isolation.
And here again, I'm referring to or
thinking about a romantic relationship.
I can see how a healthy romantic
relationship could exist in relative
isolation, a few friends, some contact
with family members, or in great
connectivity with friends and family
and neighbors, etc., and still be a
really great romantic relationship.
Paul Conti: Sure.
Andrew Huberman: I can also see how
the sorts of relationships that we
happen to be focusing on at this
moment, which are these unhealthy
dynamics, are made far worse by
lack of connectivity to outsiders.
In fact, a previous guest on this
podcast was David Buss, who's a
professor of evolutionary psychology
down at the University of Texas,
Austin, and he talked about some of
his research into the dark triad.
These are narcissistic, machiavellian,
sometimes also sociopathic
individuals, and how that plays
out in romantic relationships.
And it's a terrible thing, but an
important thing to understand given the
unfortunate frequency that that occurs.
But one of the things that I remember
so clearly from that discussion with
David Buss was that even when there
isn't sociopathy or a strong desire to
destroy the other, that in these sorts
of relationships, there's often an
attempt to isolate the person, first by
isolating them from their family, also
from friends and coworkers, but all
with the goal of convincing that person
that no one else would want them as a
way to make them "voluntarily" stay.
In other words, to undermine
their sense of safety, to ramp up
their sense of anxiety, except in
the presence of that individual.
And I'm remembering that now
because as we're talking about,
why wouldn't somebody just leave?
Why wouldn't they just tap
into that agency and gratitude?
It's clear that the oppressor in this kind
of relationship has a real incentive to
try and undermine agency and gratitude,
because, of course, with those, they
would be revealed for what they are and
the person would feel unable to leave.
Taking us back once again to the
critical need to cultivate agency and
gratitude, not just in unhealthy, but
certainly in healthy relationships.
Paul Conti: Right, and I think the
principle here is that darkness
always favors the oppressor.
So the oppressor wishes for darkness.
So you want to isolate that person
because when people see that things
are better for someone else, they
realize things can be better.
When people are told by someone
that they're worthwhile or they're
funny or they're pretty or they're
smart, or whatever the case may
be, they may take that inside.
They may take inside, oh, maybe I
am, I'm handsome and smart, maybe.
Or they start thinking about that.
They're very basic concepts that
allow a person to entertain new
ways to look at themselves, right?
So the person who's oppressing wants
that person to live in darkness.
They don't want them to see
that there can be better.
They don't want them to be directly told
that they're better than how things are.
And that same darkness on the
outside, say the lights are out
around the relationship is the goal
of the oppressor on the inside.
Now, again, the oppressor may know this
and be doing it consciously, but often
this gets played out in unconscious ways,
like the constant denigration of someone.
A person isn't saying inside, gosh, I'm
trying to reduce their agency, their
aggressive drive, really down to zero.
But that's what they're doing.
Somewhere inside, there's a knowing of
that, even if it's an unconscious knowing.
And then the impact of that kind of
abuse over time is a lower and lower and
lower ability to bring oneself to bear,
less proactive, aggressive, assertive,
lower sense of agency and gratitude.
That's really the definition
of being demoralized.
And that kind of abuse is always promoting
demoralization, because demoralization
is the darkness on the inside.
Just as envy is too, demoralization
is a form of darkness on the inside.
Envy is no less dark.
Envy may be a lot more active,
but in both cases, there's no
knowledge, there's no growth, there's
no wisdom, there's no learning.
So they're the states of darkness.
And what can happen in a way that's
really so tragic to think about is you
often can have an abuser, an oppressor,
who is living in total darkness inside,
living through the lens of envy.
And then you can have a person who is
being oppressed, who is being exploited,
who is living in darkness, but they're
living in the darkness of demoralization.
And that's a very sad thing to
say, to imagine, and it's been a
very, very sad thing to see, right?
If you do clinical psychiatry for
long enough, you see a lot of this,
and it doesn't have to be this way.
Even the people who are oppressing
have it within them the majority
of time to make things better.
And we do see that.
I took care of a man a long time ago
who had been terribly abusive to his
family and it was always unclear to
me, it had happened years before that
he just understood, and again, I never
understood what happened, that he got
it and the man really made change again.
I don't know what the circumstance was
that made that motivation to him, but he
went back and looked at himself, and he
went back and looked at how his father
oppressed and terrorized the family
and how he just did it automatically.
Because what was rooted in his own
fear of vulnerability, and he's going
to lose his family and not be a man
anymore unless he oppresses them.
He recognized all of it in him, and
he had changed it so dramatically.
He had removed himself
from the family system.
And when I got to know him, it was
years later and he was reintegrating
back into the system because there
had been such prolonged change.
And he had communicated to the
family his understanding of self.
So, it's not impossible.
Even someone who is abusing,
oppressing, coming through a
narcissistic character structure.
There's no therapeutic nihilism here.
Things can change and things can
change in the oppressor, which
isn't excusing that, right?
I mean, a person who's doing
things is morally culpable.
They often are criminally,
legally culpable.
So that is all true, just as t
he ability to change is true.
And then the person we think about more
commonly in this situation, of course,
is the person who's being oppressed.
And there can be change there, too.
But a problem is how hard it can be.
The impact of the isolation, and also the
dearth of resources to really help people.
It's an actual true story of a woman
who I believed with all my heart could
get out of the cyclic abusive situation
she was in if she had a carburetor.
A carburetor, right.
She had a car.
The car didn't function.
She had a place to go where others
wouldn't know that she was there.
And the problem was just a few hundred
dollars to change the carburetor.
But it's like there's no place to go.
There's no resources.
We as a society don't help people.
Now, it may be that someone helped
that woman and got her a carburetor
and she drove away, right?
But it shows how we can bring
ourselves to bear as a society to
offer people help, which sometimes is
like the lifeline the person needs.
And maybe that person really needs
a safe house or something very
dramatic, or they need a carburetor
to get away from being terrorized.
But a lot of times it's just community
support structures, good structures
around people in communities that can
offer them support in situations that
may be less dramatic, opportunities
for interconnection, which sometimes
people can find through social venues or
through religiously affiliated venues.
But the idea that community
support systems on all levels
make a huge difference.
There's another level, right,
beyond the relationship, right?
It's the society, it's the culture.
And that's how we, on that next level
of emergence, beyond the individual
relationships, can foster goodness, can
foster health in each and every one of us.
Andrew Huberman: How do some
of these same dynamics play out
in non-romantic relationships?
So, for instance, in the workplace, I
was weaned in academic laboratories, so
what's most familiar to me are, gosh,
unfortunately, numerous examples where
people working in laboratories, not the
same as mine, because I've been very
fortunate to have amazing benevolent
mentors, quirky and outrageous at
times, but benevolent nonetheless.
But others around me have been in
laboratories where, for instance, the
workload was just ridiculously high.
Like the demand far exceeded
what any person could do.
And if somebody had, God forbid,
a cold or children, it was near
impossible to impossible that they
could meet the standard there.
Or stress dynamics, so pressure
cooker dynamics, that made it what
anyone would call a toxic environment.
You see this also in law firms.
You see it in companies.
You see it in families.
You see it in friendship circles, right?
I mean, how many movies are about
teens oppressing one another through
bullying and ridicule and practical
jokes that are anything but funny, right,
that are downright destructive, okay?
And on and on.
And so often the victims in these
cases, if it's not a Hollywood movie,
feel as if that's their only choice.
Because to leave is to essentially
have no other options, right?
It's not that the only option is to stay.
It's that to leave is
essentially to leave science.
Because these people in positions
of power have the louder
voice, they have the megaphone.
They write the letters of
recommendation, the law firms.
People talk.
As I kind of spool this out in a
long form question, I'm realizing I
can't think of a single exception.
Like, as long as there are going to be
people interacting and people talking
about their interactions and people
in positions of power, this sort of
dynamic is going to take place, right?
Paul Conti: Absolutely.
Anytime you have a closed system without
accountability, you're just rolling
the dice for that kind of oppression.
We need accountability.
Think about theoretically what
should have happened there.
There should be higher order
accountability, whether it's in a company
or a university or wherever it may be.
There should be higher
order accountability that
is reasonable and rational.
So it's not then acting in a top down
way that would be over controlling,
telling exactly what you can and can't
say or what you can and can't do.
And sometimes there's too much
rigidity that c an be enacted top down.
But the problem runs both ways.
If there's no accountability from
the bottom up, then that person
is just simply stuck, right?
Why?
Because the system we've
put into place has failed.
And this is where we're talking
now about not just individual
relationships, two people relationships.
But now we start talking
about systems of people.
And systems of people are another level
of emergence with a personality, so to
speak, an environment all their own.
You can know everything there is to
know about each person in the system.
You don't know about the system,
but what you do know is that
accountability is necessary.
I mean, probably if we added up all
the examples in history, we'd have
to talk about them over 1000 years.
How many examples do we have that
closed systems without accountability
are just rolling the dice?
They breed oppression.
This is true.
And I've been at several different places.
So I'm not trying to implicate this
any one place versus another, but I
was part of a medical treatment team.
So this is a hierarchical medical
treatment team of maybe seven people,
give or take one, depending upon the
circumstances, where there was physical
abuse going on in the treatment team.
It's true, and I'm not saying this in some
exaggerated manner where somebody brushed
up too close to someone and they slipped.
No, hurting someone on the treatment team.
Two different people who are being
hurt by someone, seniors at a major
university in a clinical setting.
Again, it's not like that's the be all and
end all, but you think about the alleged.
The sophistication of the people in
the system, the alleged empowerment
of the people in the situation,
which did not put a stop to that.
So we need to have accountability.
The accountability has to be reasonable.
It doesn't mean over control, but it
doesn't mean under control either.
And if that person is being overworked,
as you described, with no way of
winning, or harmed on a medical team,
and there's no way that that person can
change that, the system has failed that
person and failed them dramatically.
And guess who suffers?
Everyone does, right?
That person suffers.
And the science that's being done
or the medical care that's being
provided is important to all of us.
Anyone could be the patient who is being
taken care of by the team, where one
person is hurting a couple of the others.
You think that medical care is
going to be optimized, right?
Is the science going to be optimized, that
we're utilizing to try and make our lives
better, live longer, be in less pain?
What's happening there is envy.
That person who's oppressing other
people is driven by envy, whether
it's a narcissistic character
structure that acts almost exclusively
through envy, or it's envy that is
in this person's life, in this way
or not another way, does it matter?
What's going on there is envy.
And envy is nothing but destructive.
The generative drive is
nothing but productive.
Envy is nothing but destructive.
Andrew Huberman: Could you remind,
for people that perhaps may not
have heard episodes one and two
yet, that envy is perhaps not just
a desire to be like somebody else?
That envy, in the context
that we're discussing here, is
something quite possibly different?
Paul Conti: Right, and there's a
varying lexicon, which is why it is
important to define it, because I think
people learn it in different ways.
I've heard it talked
about in different ways.
So, to define that, there's a
difference between jealousy and envy.
And again, we could choose
different words, but this is the
way I learned it that's been most
impactful, where jealousy is benign.
It's the idea that if I see t hat
you have something that I don't,
then I think, oh, well, maybe I
could work harder and get that thing.
Or if I can't have that thing,
like maybe a person is younger.
Okay, I can't make myself
younger, then I can think.
Okay, through a lens of gratitude.
Is that the only thing about me?
I can't think of anything
good about myself, right?
Other than maybe I could be younger.
I mean, if you come at that through the
lens of health, it's like, it's okay.
It can serve to motivate people to try
harder, work harder, take a look at
themselves and be more accepting of who
they are and what their circumstances
in life are, and what kind of control
they can enact and what kind they can't.
It's okay.
Envy is different.
Envy comes at that problem from
the perspective that bringing
down the other person is just as
effective as bringing up the self.
That's why envy is destructive.
So someone who might see another person
and they envy them their youth, right?
They envy.
They want that, and they want to
bring that person down because
I can't make myself younger.
But then they realize I can't
make that person older either.
But they can do other
things to them, right?
They can sexually harass them.
Maybe they can make terrible
jokes that are really insulting
and humiliating, maybe.
There are all sorts of things a person
can do to bring down someone else.
The inaction of envy is destructive.
And I truly believe this, that
people who come at the world very
strongly through envy, by and large,
a narcissistic character structure.
This is a small percentage of the
population, but that small percentage
does most of the damage on Earth.
It's a strong thing to say, but when I
think about studying political science
and thinking about history and learning
medicine and learning about psychiatry
and sociology and really trying to look
at the world and thinking, what drives
a person on a medical team who's gotten
to be a senior physician to physically
hurt doctors lower on the hierarchy?
Envy.
That person feels terrible about
themselves and then is being
destructive to those people.
Same thing.
That same thing is at work in the lab.
The same thing is at work when
people start wars of destruction
that just simply harm other people.
And we can see no other sense of it.
That from the individual setting
all the way up to the world setting,
we see the destruction of envy.
And we also see it inside of us,
because a person who's enacting envy in
the world around them is never happy.
There's no chance of happiness.
Hence the idea of a bottomless pit.
Whatever you get, let's say an
envious person who wants more money.
I want to have more money than anybody.
I want everyone to have less money
than me/ So then they come at the
world t hrough the lens of greed.
When they get more money, how
long does that make them happy?
Right?
This doesn't mean money is
bad or having money is bad.
It just means if you're coming at
the world through the lens of envy,
and that lens is specifically focused
on money, then you will be a greedy
person who is never satisfied, even
if you have 10 trillion dollars.
So it's never good.
It takes away from that person
any possibility of happiness.
And if you see people work with
people with a narcissistic character
structure, there can be a sense of a
very brief happiness in the moment.
Like, I'm happy because I realize I
have something someone else doesn't.
I'm happy because I'm thinking of myself.
And even though I feel very insecure
and vulnerable inside, I have a
whole set of defense mechanisms
that let me turn those tables around
and then feel good about myself in
a way that places me above others.
Whatever's going on in that person, it
may bring some very brief gratification
in the moment, but that's not happiness.
Hence the need for the gratification
over and over and over again.
Narcissistic people are the least
secure, most definite people on Earth.
They just have a phenomenally healthy
defensive structure that comes about
in order to try and protect them.
That leads them to go to the opposite,
some of what's called a reaction
formation, going to the very opposite,
denial, avoidance, rationalization,
projection, very unhealthy defenses
that then leads that person to protect
themselves from any help while they are
frantically trying to gain some goodness
that makes them feel good for a split
second and then disappears forever.
Hence the tremendous
predilection for destruction.
Andrew Huberman: How do you,
and how should we, think about
power dynamics in relationships?
And perhaps starting with
romantic relationships?
I've heard it said before that
there's always power dynamics
in relationships of all kinds.
I don't know if that's true or
not, but I've heard that, and I've
also heard that that's particularly
salient in romantic relationships,
independent of whether or not it's a
homosexual or heterosexual relationship.
That there's always, to some extent or
another, one leader and one follower.
This is an interesting, perhaps
a controversial idea, but I've
heard it enough times that I
want to know more about it.
Paul Conti: Sure.
Power dynamics, of course, are very
important, but also something we tend
to be so over reductionist about.
I mean, this idea, think about
that, that there's always a leader
and there's always a follower.
Every single relationship, right?
That's true o n balance, we tend
to be so reductionist, and then
what we do is we miss the real
power dynamics that are going on.
Just like I had said in a previous
episode, that I think my math minor
has helped me the most for all of life.
I think a power dynamics course
that I took as an undergraduate
in political science has helped
me the most as a psychiatrist.
Took it long before medical
school, because that class taught
me so much about power dynamics.
I thought it was going to be about
overt power, who has power over
whom and tells whom to do what.
Right?
But what I learned is that so
much of power dynamics are covert.
They're under the surface, for example,
they're the things that are not said.
Something that was called at the time,
at least, the issue of the non issue,
where there's an issue between two people.
Like, this person never
takes out the garbage.
That person always takes out the garbage.
That person is resentful about it.
Both of them know.
But the person who always does it can't
say so, because if they say so, the
first person will punish them in some
other way by not taking out the garbage.
Then the place smells, that person
goes to work, and the person
who's at home has to take it out.
Right.
That's one example of the
issue of the non issue.
Other examples are where someone is
looking and smiling and being really
nice to someone who they know is going
to physically harm them if they bring
to light that they're actually not happy
and don't feel good about that person.
So, from the dramatic to the
nondramatic, unstated power dynamics
are going on all over the place.
And they're in every single relationship.
I mean, less a person is in a
relationship with someone else
and they're both comatose.
I guess only one of
them has to be comatose.
There are power dynamics going
on, but again, it doesn't mean
that they're unhealthy, because
there are always power dynamics.
So then what are we looking for?
And again, there are a lot of things
we could look for, but we could talk
about, really two primary things.
One is, look for the nonobvious,
and t wo is the give and take.
So the first is even in
our own relationships.
Because it's interesting how many
people will, say, talk about the
power dynamics in their relationship.
They're not always saying, here are
the power dynamics in my relationship,
but they're telling me about them.
And they're telling me about
the things that are overt.
Right now, somewhere inside of them,
they know that they can't really raise
issue A, B, or C, or there'll be some
retribution, whether it's small or large.
Or they might even know everything's
okay and that person is happy.
But they know I'm not giving them
room to say that they're not happy.
And that could just mean if they say
they're not happy, then I'll come home
a couple of hours late the next day.
And that person will feel some
attachment insecurity because of that.
And there are all sorts of
ways t his can play out.
But since so much of power dynamics are
unstated or covert, kind of like the
iceberg of conscious and unconscious,
there's an iceberg of power dynamics.
So, to think about including in one's own
relationships, whether it's a neighbor,
it's a friend, it's a work relationship,
or most charged, it's romance.
What's really going on between us?
I'm not looking to tell myself lies.
I know that I may not be able
to understand all of it, but
let me stop and think about it.
And if you ask people to stop
and do that, they can say,
yeah, that's really not okay.
Because sometimes they don't know
that it's there, or they don't
want to know that it's there.
And the therapy work is
trying to guide them to.
There's an immense power disparity,
maybe in the relationship when they're
presenting, no, everything is equal.
It's a good, supportive relationship.
Hear that a lot?
And of course, it's not always that
there's something bad under the
surface, but a lot of times there is.
And even something mildly bad is
not okay and can cause problems.
And sometimes there's something very bad.
So look for the nonobvious.
And then the second is that give and
take is a very good sign of health.
Is a very good sign of health.
So if a person can kind of see that
there's give and take, and it might
be about something as simple as.
Like, who chooses where we go to dinner?
Okay, sometimes one, sometimes the other.
It depends who has a stronger feeling.
Or it may be that person always
decides where we go to dinner.
But the other person's okay with it,
and that person always decides what
movie they want, the other person.
So the idea that there's give and
take, and then in periods of time where
one person may be in a more difficult
place, one person has a significant
loss or an injury or an illness, then
you see that that shifts a little bit.
One person is giving more, right?
But then, ultimately the idea
is that's from the outside.
If one person is giving more to the
other, there's a generosity of spirit in
both the giving and the accepting that
leads them to then be stronger together.
So even when people say, well,
they're imbalances in some way.
If you just look at what's going on day
to day, but in a healthy relationship
with high generative drive, the periods
of imbalance strengthen the relationship.
You see this with friends, where
two p eople have a pretty equal
friendship, and t hen one person
has something difficult happen and
the other person is there for them.
What's true on the other side of that?
They're better friends.
And it's also why we often want to
be interconnected when we're healthy.
What if something bad
happens to both of them?
It's good to be interconnected,
and friends a nd family
can be supportive to us.
The idea that give and take is
healthy, I think, is very central.
So just looking for evidence, it's often,
if I don't understand what's going on
in the relationship, maybe it's early
in t he therapy or it's just been kind
o f opaque, or I can't figure it out.
I'm looking for, is there a give and take?
Because then I'm going to think, okay,
more likely than not, things are healthy.
If I see an imbalance, whether the
person knows it or not, I'm thinking,
more likely than not, it's unhealthy.
And then they're just clues along the
pathway of my efforts to understand.
Andrew Huberman: The non-obvious
piece is really intriguing,
as is the give and take.
And I really appreciate that you brought
up the give and take, because that's a
very concrete place that we can all look
and ask ourselves, even if people aren't
in romantic relationships, like, what is
the give and take in a given friendship?
And as you mentioned earlier,
it doesn't have to be scripted.
One for one.
Maybe it balances out over
time, or maybe it doesn't.
I mean, I've had friendships that have
lasted many decades, even where I can
honestly say I'm always the person
to reach out to the other person but
when they connect, they connect with
such a depth of attention that I
don't feel any deprivation whatsoever.
In fact, I don't think
I've ever considered that.
I'm the person that always
reaches out until today, and so
it doesn't bother me whatsoever.
I feel infinitely rewarded
in the relationship.
Like, it's generative, it
feels generative, right?
Paul Conti: It doesn't have to be
equal, however one wants to define
equal, but it has to be mutual.
You're feeling goodness
from the relationship.
So is the other person.
Okay.
That's coming from that
high generative place.
And when we really, let's say
we push that concept forward
to where we want to be living.
Not some pie in the sky, but
agency and gratitude as verbs.
The generative drive is very strongly
expressed, and the other drives are
subserving the generative drive.
Then we get to the place where we
really see it is true that it is
better to give than to receive.
The happiest people I see are
the people who are giving.
Now, of course, it feels great to
receive, but it feels better to
give because there's a goodness
in the self, in the giving.
And I remember seeing this as a child and
being too young to understand it, b ut I
was a little kid, I liked getting things.
And as a little kid, I liked getting
things more than I liked giving.
Like, that's okay when
you're a little kid.
But what I did observe is that my maternal
grandmother, who is very sweet and loving
and caring, she loved giving, right?
You give her presents.
And we did.
And she really liked getting presents.
She loved giving.
There was an excess of goodness.
And then as I got older and I learned
more, like who she had been in the
community and how she had been to people.
And I could see, and now, through
the lens that there was such goodness
in her, I think she's, for me, she's
the shining model of goodness that I
internalize as I aspire to be better.
So then I think I want to be like that.
I am more generative as I try and
think more about giving than receiving.
I'm not trying to say I'm some
noble person or I'm being ascetic.
I'm thinking that's a good
way for u s all to feel right.
Or someone, a very, very successful person
that I consult to that is in my life,
who talked about how he always makes
inside of himself the best understanding
of what's going on between him and
another person, whether it's a very big
financial deal or it's about power or
it's personal and then gives a little bit.
Always, where have we ended up?
Let me give a little bit, right.
And there's a person who's very,
very s uccessful, very, very happy.
But I would argue the goodness in
him is why he's successful and happy.
It's not that he's successful
and therefore he's happy.
Right.
It's what's inside of him that
fosters both of those good things.
And he could be just as happy
without the big success.
Maybe he wouldn't.
Maybe he wasn't minded to do that.
And he grows a nice garden.
He could be equally happy.
But the point is the goodness
in self, to be able to do that,
to feel good about doing that.
I feel better about giving that
than I would have receiving that.
That's pretty stark, right?
It's something given to the other
that I would have gotten right now,
and we're in maybe a negotiation to
give it feels better than to have it.
Andrew Huberman: I'm sure there
are many people thinking about
individuals who are highly successful,
who are not givers, who are takers.
I do think those examples of takers, as
I'm calling them, grab a lot of attention.
But I know, at least within science
and the other domains of life I've
been in, that there are far more
successful people who are also
givers, even to a great extent.
And of course, that doesn't mean
that they're giving to the point
of an inability to give further
or to take care of themselves.
The giving is part of taking
care of themselves, but it's
part of this generative cycle.
It's not one thing.
It's not a tit for tat.
It's part of something that makes them
feel good, makes others feel good.
It's sort of anti transactional.
And as we're talking about the self
and interrelations between selves
in these different relationship
contexts today, this word
transactional keeps coming to mind.
And what I'm so aware of as you're
describing what healthy selves and
healthy relationships look like, is
that it runs counter to pretty much
everything that I've heard and that we
hear in the world about relationships
and about the relationship to self,
meaning it's not transactional.
It's really about a cycle.
And we're using this word generative over
and over in its specific context today.
So I don't want to rob that word for
a different purpose, but I'm imagining
a sort of upward spiral in my mind,
or perhaps something that's really
like a circle of life that just keeps
growing bigger and bigger and bigger.
Maybe we could talk a little
bit about this notion of
relationships being transactional.
I mean, it's such a loaded word, but
I have a close friend who's married
with more than a few children who
told me the other day, I realized
that it's all kind of transactional.
Like they're extracting from me and
I'm extracting from them, and it's
benevolent because it's all good.
And I thought, wow,
this is really dreadful.
No one wants to think that
the closest relationships in
their lives are transactional.
And he was coming to that conclusion.
I disagreed with him, and I don't know
where that all sits for him right now.
But maybe we could talk about the
transactional versus non-transactional
aspects of relationship,
because we all want things.
That's perfectly healthy.
I believe we all experience
disappointment and pleasure and relief,
and sometimes major disappointment,
pleasure, relief, et cetera.
But what is the role of
transaction in relationships?
And how does psychiatry, how do you,
and how should we think about that?
Paul Conti: Well, we often get confused
because there are transactions in every
relationship, but that does not mean
that every relationship is transactional.
So if we think about what
transactions are, we can think of
in kind of the stereotypical way.
So it can also be like,
here's the transaction.
I'll do the dishes, and you
wash the clothes, right?
Andrew Huberman: Or, for instance,
I'll make the money, and the other
person will raise the children.
Paul Conti: Right.
So there are transactions.
But that does not mean that the be
all and end all of it are sort of
hard hearted, calculated transactions.
And transactions also occur in less
obvious but equally important ways.
So another way that transactions occur is
right now I'm putting something out there.
Because I'm saying something, right?
And then at a point, I stop
and I'm waiting for you to
put something out there.
And then I take in what you said,
and we're doing something that
in that sense is transactional.
I'm waiting for you to give me something.
I take it in, I process it, I
give something back out to you.
But that's not the be
all and end all of it.
So there are transactions, whether it's
who's going to wash the dishes, who's
going to do the clothes, or it's what d
o I put out there that you take in, a nd
what do you put out there that I take in?
That there is something greater than
something beyond the transactional.
And there is some controversy to
this, a thought that there really is
a historical thought in the field.
That there are just aggressive
and pleasure drives in us, and
that everything is transactional.
Now, again, we don't really
have a way of disproving that.
I mean, there's not going to be
some equation that disproves that.
But I think it's entirely
disproven by human experience.
And there's so many, we could talk
about an infinite number of resources
to consider this, but just imagine
the writings of Viktor Frankl and
the writings and the theories around
human interactions and psychological
theories that have come of it.
To think that everything is just
transactional, it's a denial of the
humanness in all of us that I think he
just brought to the fore so strongly.
But again, there could be nearly
infinite resources throughout
human history that say, hey,
we're not entirely transactional.
It's not just aggression and pleasure,
but there's something more going on here.
There's learning that feels
good for the sake of learning.
There's kindness that feels
good for the sake of kindness.
There's giving that feels good,
because giving feels good.
This is going on in us.
It's going on when we're, like, loving
children, for example, or loving animals.
There's something inside of us
that's not just transactional.
And that's why I think what we're
talking about is, if it's truth,
it should all hang together, right?
It must all hang together.
And this is why there's an us over top of
each individual that's in a relationship.
This is why you can know
everything about me.
You can know everything about you, and
you can know nothing about our friendship.
Absolutely nothing, right?
Because it's something different.
And if it were all just transactional,
there would be nothing different, right?
And I think our experience as human
beings, I know that to be true,
because I just know that I don't
always feel selfish about things.
Like, maybe sometimes I do,
and I do something nice because
it'll make me look good.
Like, okay, we're all human, right?
But I know that there's good
feeling from others towards me.
At times, that's just
about the good feeling.
I know that there's that
from me towards others.
So that tells us, yes, there is
something other than just the I.
There is the we of dyads, right, of
relationships, no matter whether they're
work, family, friendship, relationship.
And then there are the levels
beyond that that are larger "we"s.
The we of groups.
Andrew Huberman: So if I understand
correctly, it can be the case that
one person makes the majority or all
of the income for a family, the other
person raises the children, takes
care of the majority of the home.
And of course, there is a transaction
there, a set of transactions, but that
it's in service to something larger
that really isn't transactional.
I'm just stealing your words here,
but if I were to expand on that,
just to make sure I understand that
the non-transactional thing that
emerges from that is generative,
because it's a family, right?
It's a family that everyone can extract
growth and pleasure and meaning from.
And just because the roles are divided
as such, it doesn't necessarily mean
that the relationship is defined
as transactional in the sense
that it's less than it could be.
Paul Conti: Right.
If you think about what's
really being transacted.
So, say one person is out in the
world and is making an income.
The other person is, say, taking care of
the family and taking care of the home.
What's being transacted?
Well, the person who's making the
money is sharing the money, right?
In that sense, transacting some
of the money to the other person.
Like, you get to have some of it, too.
You get to have some
of the benefit from it.
And the person who is at home,
who's taking care of the family
in the home, saying, you get to
have some of that too, right?
You get to come home, the
children are taken care of, right?
The home is taken care of.
So both are transacting
something to the other.
I mean, that's the truth of it.
If you look at what's really going
on there, one person's getting the
benefit of money they didn't earn,
the other person's getting benefits.
They have childcare they
didn't do or pay for.
They're not paying for childcare,
they're sharing resources.
So, yes, that's true.
But is that it?
Are these two robots?
One is the money making robot, and
the other is the childcare robot.
That's not what's going on.
The way we want to envision that,
i f we have two healthy people with
g enerative drives is they love one
another, they're creating something better
than they could create on their own.
In fact, they've created children,
they've created a home together, and
they're nurturing that family together.
That is generative.
And because it's generative,
it can also be flexible.
So let's say the person who's
at home says, I need to do some
things outside of the house, right?
Or let's say the person who's out working
thinks, oh, my God, I feel overwhelmed.
And I like to switch to a better
job, but that job's halftime.
I could be half in the house, right?
This is where people can come
together in the same way.
We talked about the two and an eight on
the sex drive or sexuality scale, where
people then can find compromises, right?
And if one really wants to stay out of
the home all the time, but the person in
the home wants to leave the home, well,
they find a way that that works, right?
Because their care for one another,
the generative spirit that is
in them individually and as a
couple, lets them nurture that.
And one isn't interested
in oppressing the other.
I'm not going to leave my job.
You stay at home or I'm staying at home.
You stay out there.
It's like, okay, let's think about things.
Let's communicate, right?
That's how the generative drive not
only makes that awesome, like the
five isn't the compromised position
between the eight and the two.
The five is awesome right here.
The transactional aspects are awesome
because of the generative aspects of
what comes of it far more than either
of those people could make on their own.
I mean, one would say it's not so obvious.
Maybe if one makes X amount of
dollars, each could make half X.
That's not what we're talking about.
Neither of them can create
that family on their own.
Andrew Huberman: It seems that so
much of what we're talking about
relies on the hallmarks that we always
hear make up good relationships of
all kinds, romantic and otherwise.
Things like communication, listening,
generosity, all the stuff that we all know
that we should bring to relationship and
hopefully are getting from relationships.
And that if we're not, that
we should probably request
from others in polite ways.
Paul Conti: Right.
I have one word for that.
Kindergarten.
Right?
Think about that.
We learned that in kindergarten.
What you're describing is so simple.
That's why it's so high up on the,
this is what the geyser is pushing up.
It's high up from the two pillars,
because what you're talking about is
simple generosity of spirit, giving
rather than taking, being kind to
others, letting things go, feeling good
about yourself, even if you fall down.
We learn this in kindergarten.
So we must, somewhere inside of us,
really value it, but then we let it go.
We make things overly complex.
And this idea that in many ways
we should go back to kindergarten
because there's a purity there.
Children at an age where they can
learn, and then we bring a nice kind
of learning to them and a nurturing
to them and we can bring it to
ourselves, too, so that we simplify
that which has become overly complex.
We simplify because
trauma makes complexity.
Having to just make one's way in
the world is complicated, right?
So things get more and more complicated
and we lose the simple roots of
goodness or the goodness of simplicity,
and we can come back to that.
So I couldn't resist when you said,
oh, these simple, these basic things.
That's the point of it, because
that's where agency and gratitude
and the generative drive, that's
where they live in the simplicity.
Andrew Huberman: I'm glad
you mentioned kindergarten.
It brought me back to images of
kindergarten where, yeah, as far
as I can remember now, there were
all the critical components of
a great generative environment,
adults who really cared about us.
Fortunately, there were snack time
with oranges, so nourishing food,
there was nap time in the afternoon.
Like, these things are all things--
Paul Conti: You got
some exercise, explore.
Andrew Huberman: You could take a
guinea pig home on the weekends.
They had this guinea pig.
I think there were several guinea
pigs, but they kept trying to convince
us it was the same guinea pig because
they would allow one family to take
home the guinea pig each weekend.
And sometimes I think it
didn't work out quite so well.
But anyway, the guinea pig
was a pervasive feature.
So you learned to take care of things.
And in all seriousness, now that I
step back from it, there's nothing
more generative, it seems, than a
kindergarten classroom environment,
or we should say a healthy
kindergarten classroom environment.
It's all about support of others.
And if we go to the pillars, the structure
of self and the function of self, surely
there's a lot going on at home, too.
But think about what's salient.
It's learning messages of self
confidence, like instilling those.
It's behaviors that are based
on strivings and hopefulness.
It's all the good things.
Yes, all the good things.
And so, as I was thinking about
communication and all these good things,
that clearly kindergarten is a wonderful
template for, in all seriousness
I think, is an amazing template.
I'm thinking about what gets in the way,
and of course, trauma can get in the
way, and we should talk about that more.
But it seems to me that one of the things
that gets in the way of asking for what
we want, of hearing requests of us in
the way that is going to bring about the
most generative goodness, is anxiety.
It's like you're tired from a
long day and someone mentions,
we have to take the trash out.
I was at work all day.
That kind of thing or earlier you
were talking about the issue of the
non issue in terms of power dynamics.
Well, let's just say I've had the
experience before in relationship of
feeling like if I make a request or I
have a quote unquote complaint about
something, that the other person is
going to be so upset about the fact
that they didn't do something well,
that it's going to be three days of
just diminished happiness for everybody.
So I just assume, not deal with it, right?
So when we hear the word anxiety, I
think we often think about the person,
like quaking about public speaking
or like getting the circuits in
their brain hijacked that were only
designed for saber toothed tigers.
But anxiety seems to serve both
a very important functional role
in modern life that has nothing
to do with physical threat.
But it also seems to be the feature
that if not kept in check, if we can't
regulate our own anxiety, I'm realizing
there's no way that we're going to
be in a position to ask for what we
need and what we want, to hear what's
needed of us and what others want.
In other words, anxiety seems like a
major barrier to the generative drive.
Paul Conti: I think the place to start
is i f you show me a person who has
no anxiety, I'll show you a mannequin.
We all have anxiety in us.
Remember, it's just a word, right?
What are we getting at?
We're getting at a sense of tension
or a sense of disquiet inside of
us that we would like to solve, we
would like to ease, if we could.
It is not helpful or healthy if
we have very, very low levels of
that, because then our strivings
are certainly going to suffer.
There's not a lot of motivation
to go make change in the
world, a change in our lives.
So if we have too little of that
tension, that doesn't go well.
And of course, that maps
to a low assertiveness,
aggression, proactive drive.
There are other ways that could
show i tself, but it maps very
clearly, I think, to that.
And that's not good for us on
the other end of the spectrum.
We're much more concerned with the
other end of the spectrum because a
lot of anxiety feels very, very bad
and it feels very bad right now, right?
So our high levels of anxiety,
they narrow our cognitive spectrum.
They narrow our ability to think
about what's going on around
us, to think about ourselves.
So the idea with anxiety is
to recognize, hey, we all have
it, and we can call it anxiety.
We can call it tension.
We can call it whatever we
want t o, but we want that to
be i n a healthy place, right?
Which comes, of course, back to the self,
that if my levels of anxiety are very
high and therefore it's causing problems
in my relationship, like maybe I'm
always asking my partner if we're okay.
That happens a lot.
Like, are we okay?
Are you happy?
Because there's a lot of anxiety in me.
The first place to go
is to look at myself.
So we could say, oh, I
have attachment insecurity.
That's just stating the obvious, right?
Andrew Huberman: Or, sorry to
interrupt, but a very common one
nowadays that I think is new in
the course of human history is
the tugging the line phenomenon.
You text somebody, you're thinking
about them, you don't hear back,
and then tension starts to mount.
And then depending on the context,
you may either be concerned about
the person or even suspicious
about what the person is up to.
I mean, here it's very contextual, right?
And it depends on the history of both
individuals and that relationship.
But then the person will reach
back eventually and it either
will bring relief or relief with
some resent, like, where were you?
What happened?
This is very, very common.
So much so, in fact, that I've
come to learn in talking to
others, and this is the classic...
I have a friend who, but really
others who are in the landscape
of looking for a relationship.
And there are people I know well who
go through a lot of effort to set an
intermittent schedule of response.
Like to not give the other
person the sense that they always
respond with short latency.
Because, indeed, sometimes they will be
able to do that and sometimes they won't.
What they're basically trying to do is
make sure that the person doesn't, they're
actually trying to take care of the
other person in addition to themselves.
Because I think we come to expect
a certain latency of response
with certain individuals.
And if we don't hear back with that
particular latency of response,
our own anxiety starts to pick up.
And it can be quite damaging to a
relationship, in particular to the
generative drives within us, because
in that time that we're stressed,
we're not tending to other things,
including things that we could do for the
relationship that we're so worried about.
Paul Conti: The famous scene in Swingers,
right, where t he person leaves a message
and then lives the whole relationship
in his own m ind and breaks up with the
person and they never actually spoke.
There's the anxiety run wild.
And of course, I remember that
was very popular when it came out.
Why?
Because it resonated with the
insecurities we feel and now with the
ability to feel those insecurities
in a much more immediate way.
That person didn't text me back.
There's a lot more of that inside o f
us, which really points to if you're able
to identify that you're anxious, too.
Anxious for comfort, which, again,
if one looks inside or even listens,
maybe to what others have said or
reflected, like, there's a lot of
data, especially introspection, t
o be able to identify that, right?
The next question is always, why?
Let's go look at that.
Maybe that person has been
anxious their whole life.
Maybe they just have
run tense all the time.
You know what?
Sometimes a little bit of medicine
that kind of just pulls that down.
P erson can take that for 50 years, life
is better, t here's no side effects, s o
sometimes that might be the case, right?
Sometimes the person's anxiety kind of
grew throughout childhood, and maybe
that's because there were difficult
things or traumatic things that happened.
Maybe there was nothing like that,
but maybe the person was very good at
engaging in the world and then felt
more and more pressures upon themselves.
And no one ever did anything wrong,
and they've only been rewarded.
But regardless, look at
the anxiety in yourself.
Go back to those pillars, right?
And one might discover, for example,
maybe the anxiety I'm feeling is
attributable to the other person.
Am I feeling anxious
because I'm intimidated?
Am I feeling anxious because I
know that if I don't behave in a
certain way, the next time there's
a group meeting, there'll be
some snarky joke made about me.
So, anxiety, sometimes it's the self.
Sometimes it's got a lot
of biological components.
Sometimes it's got a lot of
psychological components.
Sometimes both.
Sometimes it's the environment.
Sometimes it's the other.
The other person.
So look at why.
Because that's how we learn.
Like, what is going on inside of me?
Where is that level of anxiety?
How does it not feel comfortable?
What actually is it?
How is it changing, how I'm behaving?
How might it be changing?
How am I responding to it?
So, what are we doing?
We're going back to this, look in those
10 cabinets and figure out why, which we
can do the vast majority of times between
ourselves and the use of others, either
professionally or non professionally.
We can go understand the
anxiety or the lack of anxiety.
Why am I not so motivated?
Right?
I mean, that's the case with a lot
of people who feel demoralized.
They don't feel they can
get anywhere in the world.
The world's a bad place, and how are
you going to make your way in the world?
And they start feeling nihilistic, or
they feel like the eight ball is against
them, even in a generational capacity.
And now they feel demoralized, and the
tension inside is soothed by things.
So maybe that's the person who's
overusing the thing that soothes, right.
So they could go look at, hey, I
was kind of motivated and did well
in sports or did well in this, was
interested in that, what's going on?
That's how a person could identify,
for example, being demoralized.
So that process of inquiry gives
us the information that we can
use in the service of change.
And the change, while not achieved
100% of the time, the change for
the better is predictable if it's
arising from a place of understanding.
Andrew Huberman: I'm very curious
about frames of mind in relationship.
In particular, how being in our own
experience, say, anxious because someone
hasn't responded to us and really paying
attention to the anxiety and drilling into
it and asking ourselves, why am I anxious?
And do I deserve to be anxious?
Is it about me or is it about them?
Whether or not that's a valid pursuit,
or whether or not focusing on the
other person and trying to imagine
what's going on in their head, that
they might be doing this or that
they seem to do something repeatedly.
This, of course, relates to much more
than just the scenario of waiting for
a text message and feeling anxious.
I think so much of how we come into
relationships of all kinds, romantic
certainly, but family relationships
are in and around the tendency to
switch back and forth, sometimes
seemingly at random, between our own
experience and what am I feeling?
What am I experiencing?
And then thinking about the other.
Like, what are they thinking?
What are they experiencing?
I mean, this has everything
to do with human dynamics.
I would think that it's near impossible
for the typical person to just live
life through their own frame and
lens and never pay attention at all
to what others might be thinking.
Even, for instance, the most exploitive,
extractive narcissist sociopath presumably
is thinking about who in the room
is going to be their target because
of how that person might be feeling.
And of course, on the benevolent side,
people who want to do positive, generative
things in the world are probably thinking
about who to align with, who has common
goals that they might want to work with
or be with romantically that could help
them and the other person generate.
So what is this thing that we do?
What is it called, and how does it work
to place ourselves in the mind of others?
And what roles does it serve and what
goals does it undercut when we do this?
Paul Conti: Well, I think the first
thing to say is that everything
follows the same simple pattern.
So I start with thinking about me, right?
If I'm anxious, why am I anxious?
What's going on inside of me?
Then I think about you.
Are you anxious too?
Or maybe I'm not anxious,
but I notice that you are.
So there's the thought about the
I, because I can't think in a
clear headed way about you unless
I've thought about me, right?
Because if I'm really, really
anxious, then how am I supposed
to understand and try and get an
idea of where you're at, right?
So then where do we arrive?
We arrive at the magic bridge of the us.
That's what connects us.
Whether the us is a friendship, it's a
professional relationship, it's romance.
There's the bridge of the us.
Because it's not just
how or when am I anxious.
How or when are you anxious?
What are things like when we're together?
Maybe that.
Maybe I'm anxious when we're together.
And what's that tension about?
Or you're anxious when we're together.
And maybe that's for reasons we
could talk about and make less.
Maybe there's some insecurity in one
of us, or maybe the other person is
behaving in a certain way that's not
making the second person feel good.
We can then come together and see
how does the us impact the level
of anxiety, and how do we then take
away from the us being stronger?
So think about, w e talked
about the trauma bond.
Trauma bond can be
enacted in a negative way.
It can be enacted in a positive way.
And those two people who can go to
the museum together, who can't go
to the museum separately, they're
living in the magic bridge of the us.
They're both at the museum, but
neither can go to the museum.
Neither can go to the museum,
but both can go to the museum.
And then they take away
stronger selves from that.
That's a reinforcing experience.
It's positive.
It builds the generative drive.
It builds confidence.
The person went, they were assertive,
and that was gratified in a good
way, and they felt pleasure.
So when we look at the us, it is about
the us in the moment, but it is also
about how two people are impacting one
another in the rest of their lives.
And of course, this is more important
the closer the relationship, like this
is very important, for example, in close
friendships or family relationships.
And I think this is of extreme
importance in relationships.
These are the two people who presumably
are the closest to one another on Earth.
So a shared us that promotes understanding
and bolsters a sense of agency and
gratitude and bolsters the generative
drive that's great for both people
when they're not in the us, when
one goes one way and one goes the
other, because that happens all the
time in relationships, too, right?
Go to work at different places or
we bolster ourselves outside of
relationships if we see what the magic
bridge of the relationship can be.
So, we can look there for
problems like, why am I anxious?
Why are you anxious?
Why are we anxious?
Why are you only anxious
when we're we and not...?
We can look for all that,
and we should, right?
But we can also even more
powerfully look for the good there.
How can our shared bond, whatever
it may be, be better for both of us?
And what stronger incentive could there
be than to do that in relationships?
Romantic relationships, the ones that
are closest to us, if they're not
romantic, they could be friendships.
Whatever our closest relationships are,
they're the most important vehicles,
so to speak, to better health and
happiness, to getting to that place
of peace and contentment and delight.
The us is very, very powerful.
In fact, even more powerful
than the I and the you.
Andrew Huberman: When thinking about
the us and trying to understand why
somebody that we know and are in
relationship with is behaving the way
they are or might be feeling or claiming
they feel the way that they are.
How useful do you think it is for
us to put ourselves in their shoes?
I can think of all sorts of ways
in which this could be beneficial.
I can also think of all sorts of ways
in which it would be focusing off the
self and our own experience in ways that
might be defensive avoidance or denial.
Yeah, I'll come clean.
I mean, there have been plenty of times
in relationship where I get fixated on
why someone is the way they are, behaved
the way they did, and more often than not,
by taking a step back and thinking about
why my reaction to that is the way it is.
I don't solve the "problem," but I get a
lot further along in terms of quelling my
own anxiety and finding a path forward.
Paul Conti: Right.
Well, mentalization, which is the
ability to discern feeling states,
intention states in self and others.
But now we're looking for others, right?
So the ability to understand feeling
states, what's going on inside of you?
Intention.
What are your intentions?
That should only be good, because if
we're seeing it through a clear lens,
meaning a lens that's not biased by
some problem, like a defense mechanism
of rationalization, for example, or of
projection, if we're seeing clearly,
we're learning about the other.
And the learning is never bad.
Knowledge, truth is good.
So if we learn about the other by,
in that sense, putting ourselves in
their shoes, then we gain information.
But it's the health in us that
is so crucial to what we do
with that information, right?
So one person could say, put themselves
in the other person's shoes and
they can say, okay, that person, I
can see that person's responding.
And they say, pretty calm,
pretty calm about something.
And maybe that's just a good thing.
Maybe there's some contention going
on and that person's maintaining
their cool and that person is going
to be really helpful in navigating
an argument or a disagreement to
some really positive endpoint.
So, if a person sees clearly,
okay, I can see that you're calm.
And I also see that you're trying to
figure things out and the things that
you're saying are sort of positive.
You're disagreeing with me,
but you don't seem to mean ill.
Then I can see, you know what?
I think your calm is good, because I'm
getting a little bit upset and you're not.
And I see that there's
a benevolence in you.
So maybe you'll guide us to the
p lace that maybe I can't, right?
But think about if there's
not a clear lens inside of me.
If I have a defense system that leads
me to externalize, responsibility that
leads me to project or leads me to do
all sorts of things that are not healthy.
Now I might think, well, you're calm
because you just don't care about me.
I mean, so think of the same exact thing.
Now in the example we're giving the person
in your position is like being really
benign and benevolent, but it happens
all the time where that is misconstrued.
So it's not that the insight,
that person is calm, I see that
they're calm, it's that there's
a deficit in the mentalization.
The person is not fully
understanding their intention.
What's coming through then gets distorted.
So, we think about defense mechanisms.
They can be clear, they can let light
through in this beautiful way that has
fidelity, or they can be very distorting.
So the thought that, if I'm discerning
that you are benevolent and you seem to be
trying to solve the problem for us, but I
take in and you just don't care about me
and you're trying to put one over on me.
If I've assessed it accurately,
but it comes on the other
end in a way that's changed.
That's because there's a lack of
clarity , there's distortion inside of me.
Right?
So then if I'm really working on
myself, I'm in the best place I
can be, I'm going to be better
at mentalizing about you and me.
Even if I say, well, we're having a
disagreement, I know I tend to get
a little defensive, so I'm going t
o be a little biased to see w hat's
in you in a kind of negative way.
So what am I seeing like, okay, you're
pretty calm, maybe you don't care.
I know I can think that, right?
But come on, you're trying.
You want to solve our problem.
Imagine when that goes on inside
of a person, which sometimes
goes on consciously or goes on
unconsciously or some mixture.
It's so powerful.
The person is aware of their own state,
which helps them to be aware of the
state of the others, of the other.
And then the information they're
getting comes through with fidelity.
And now all of a sudden, instead of
maybe I'm going to blow things up now
I'm allying with you in solving our
problem because I see clearly about you
and me and that's going on all the time.
It might sound, well, it's complicated.
There's a lot of back and forth, right?
There are millions of things
going on every split second in our
unconscious mind that is throwing
all this up to the conscious mind.
It's doing things rapidly that's
going on all the time in us, whether
we want to acknowledge it or not.
And we choose not to acknowledge it at our
own peril because then we're not going to
those two pillars and their 10 cupboards.
We're not going to the structure of
self, the function of self, and what
comprises those two pillars to look for.
Hey, what's going on?
Right, let me understand better.
And even if things are going well, we
can always, as you said not that long
ago, we can understand ourselves better.
The stronger I am, the more generative
drive there is in me, the less
defensiveness, the more the agency and
the gratitude, the more I'm armed for
whatever difficult thing comes my way.
So if there's a conflict with
someone, w hether there should be or
there shouldn't b e, maybe someone's
being really aggressive and I've
got to kind of say some things
and try and counter that, right?
I'm going to be able to
discern one from another.
I'm going to be more effective in both.
I just set myself up for success,
and if I'm setting me up for success,
then I'm also setting you up for
success if you're someone I have a
relationship with, no matter what it is.
And then ultimately I'm setting the
we right, the magical bridge of us.
I'm setting that up for success too.
And that's how you see in these
levels of emergence, that if you
understand everything about you and
understand everything about me, and
let's say a person understands we
have a generative drive, you don't
really know what our relationship is
going to be like, but you think, I bet
it's going to be a good one, right?
And then what would we then
contribute, s ay, to a broader culture?
So a group of people, maybe there's
10 people, a bunch of friends getting
together, we would contribute goodness
at that next level, which is then
the culture o f the larger group.
Andrew Huberman: In hearing your
description of mentalization, this
ability for all of us to get into
the mind of another and to try
and imagine motivations and states
that would explain their behavior--
Paul Conti: And the self, right?
The mind of self and other.
Andrew Huberman: Yeah, that seems
like a natural reflex that's healthy.
And it seems to surface most
often as the consequence of
negative interactions, right?
Something didn't go right.
And so we kind of explore
like, was it them?
Was it me?
Was it something that happened before?
What else is going on with this person
as a way to try and arrive at some sort
of hopefully generative understanding.
But it seems to me that there's also
great value in mentalizing about others
under conditions in which things are
going well, so that one can potentially
make things or encourage things to go
even better in future interactions.
Paul Conti: Right.
Well, the first thing I would
say i s, I think the reflex
is most often not mentalizing.
That the reflex is most often
not mentalizing, r ight?
Because the reflexes often come
from a position of not feeling safe.
There's some conflict.
I don't feel good.
If there's some conflict, people, we
often get very defensive very quickly,
whether we show it on the outside
or we start partitioning inside.
And the problems come not from
mentalizing, but they come from
not mentalizing and not being
aware of the difference, because
then I conclude, I know what's
going on in you and I don't right.
Because I don't know
what's going on in me.
Right.
And I think you're being aggressive.
Really.
I'm feeling kind of defensive.
I'm feeling vulnerable, and
then I'm getting aggressive.
But I can't handle that because
I don't want to be aggressive.
So you're aggressive.
So there's such a difference between, say,
coming at a self other conflict from the
perspective of, say, not mentalizing, but
thinking that you are versus mentalizing.
There's a difference between, is it me?
I know it can't be.
Is it you?
It must be.
Right?
And that's how a lot of that goes.
And then, of course, what's the
data t hat's gathered, the data
that's gathered supports that.
I mean, I think there's wars I
think have happened based upon
this, let alone conflicts in
friendships and in relationships.
The key about mentalizing
is that's not what it is.
Mentalizing.
It goes like this.
Is it me?
Is it you?
Is it us?
Let's figure that out.
Let's figure it out together.
It's not defensive, it's not aggressive.
It's not projecting.
It's really actually seeing.
And look, if it's me, I want to be
aware of it and say, yeah, like, whoa,
I got up on the wrong side of the bed.
Let me just say I'm sorry, right?
Or if I might say, look, I know
that you're being aggressive and
you normally wouldn't be, and say,
look, let me just get away from it?
Let the person I care about
calm down, come back later.
Or if it's us, is really something
b etween us, then let's sort it out.
The information that allows the healthy,
the agency and gratitude decisions
is always there through mentalizing.
The danger is when we're not
mentalizing, but we think we are.
Andrew Huberman: Got it.
In keeping with thinking about
others and what's going on with them.
Mentalizing, that is, and in thinking
about what's going on with ourselves and
the exploration of the cupboards under
the pillars of structure of self, function
of self and our desire for all of that
to geyser up into agency and gratitude.
One thing that we hear about so
much these days, and generally I
think it's good that people are
talking about them, are boundaries.
You've crossed my boundary,
or I'm setting a boundary.
And I've certainly embedded the
message in my head that in order
for certain relationships to be
at their most loving in my life,
sometimes the boundaries require very
little frequency of communication.
But that doesn't mean the
relationships aren't ongoing.
So what are your thoughts on boundaries?
And how should we think about boundaries
for the sake of healthy relationships?
Paul Conti: Well, healthy
boundaries always start inside.
And then once we have them squared away
inside, we can project them outward.
The same as everything works, right?
It starts with the self, and
then it includes the other.
So let's say you took an
example of a friend who's just
a little too presumptuous.
Like the kind of person you'd rather k
nock on your door, but who just opens the
door and comes in, that kind of thing.
And you like the person a lot, and
there's a lot of resonance, and you
don't want to lose the friendship.
Let's imagine what could happen here.
It's not the only thing that can
happen, but a thought experiment, right?
So the person may then question
themselves, like, is there
something wrong with me?
Because I don't really like this
person coming in my front door.
Is that just me?
Am I being weird about that?
Or the person can kind of stop
and think about that, and they can
take stock of self, and they can
arrive at an answer for themselves.
Like, look, that person may
conclude that, you know what?
People I'm as close to as this
person come in my front door.
You know what?
That's okay, right?
I don't need to set a boundary there.
That's possible, right?
More often, what the person concludes
is, no, I don't really want that.
I do actually want this
person to knock on the door.
And that's okay.
There's not something wrong with me.
It's not that I'm being a jerk.
It's not that I'm being
a bad friend, right?
Because what are they saying?
You might say, oh, they're preparing
for what the other person could
say, but no, they're countering what
they're testing out to themselves.
Does that mean I'm a bad friend?
No, right?
That kind of thing.
So they know, and then they
understand, and they have the
right to set the boundary, right?
Like, okay, it's my house.
I try to be generous, but I still
don't want people coming in the door.
Like, you come to some conclusion
that setting the boundary is okay and
you're squared away with it inside.
Then you communicate the boundary
outward, and you decide, how
do I want to communicate that?
Like saying, hey, man, don't
come in the front door anymore.
That's not so good right now, the
friendship is really on the rocks, right?
But to say to someone something like,
yeah, look, I care about you, and I trust
you, and I know you feel the same way
about me, but it just makes me nervous
when people just come in the door.
Do you mind?
Is it okay if you just
please knock on the door now?
Think about how that's been done.
It's so accurate to what's going on inside
the person, to how the person wants to
communicate with the other, then you have
the highest likelihood of effectiveness.
And the person also, in that sense, has
sort of the clean conscience, so to speak,
that lets them take in information back.
So let's say the other person hopefully
has a high generative drive and
all the good things we're talking
about could say, oh, I'm sorry.
I didn't mean to make
you feel uncomfortable.
I kind of just automatically do that,
or I always do that at my brother's
house when it's close by or whatever.
The person is saying, no worries,
okay, everything is fine.
Right?
But let's say that
person does get mad now.
You know, like, whoa, what's
going on in this person?
Because what you're doing is you're seeing
signs of unhealth in the other person.
And it may be that, whoa, that's
not so healthy with the person.
But I like other aspects of the
friendship, and that seems like
kind of a strange idiosyncrasy.
Then you might decide, you know what?
I want to keep this friendship.
So I'll start locking the door, and the
person has to knock, or you might think,
okay, am I seeing something here that's
about lack of consideration, right?
That's about selfishness.
That ultimately may be about envy.
I'm going to walk into your
house and ruin your privacy.
house and make you feel anxious.
I feel entitled to do that.
The kind of thing that's really
coming through the lens of envy.
So then you start thinking about
that, and maybe not always.
Of course, sometimes you find a
friend who can do the right thing.
Sometimes you find a friend who can't, and
you can still make the friendship work.
Sometimes you find a person who's not
a friend, and you see, like, oh, that's
how e verything is with this person.
You realize, like, there's no us.
There's no us, right.
And that's how people can leave
relationships that ultimately are
exploitive in one way or another.
Whether it's a friendship, it's a romance,
if a person really understands, there's
the me, the you, the magical bridge of us.
And then, wait, there's
no magical bridge of us.
I feel that there's a magical bridge
of us, but the other person doesn't.
There's immense power of
understanding and then of appropriate
self care and self protection.
Andrew Huberman: Over and over again.
Not just during today's episode,
but in the previous two episodes.
It seems that getting squared away
with oneself, or at least one's own
internal processes to some degree,
gaining some insight as to where the
negative or even positive emotion
within us is arising when we're in
relationship to anyone or anything.
It just seems so key.
It's like the foundation of it.
You said getting to the maximum amount of
agency and gratitude is the goal, really.
And that's done by cycling back
through the cupboards that reside under
structure of self and function of self.
And asking questions about oneself.
And really, unless we are trained
psychiatrists like you, none of
us really should be doing that
for the other person, it seems.
This is really each and all of
our own responsibility to do for
ourselves, but that it serves
others in so many positive ways.
Paul Conti: Right.
Right.
So mentalization greases the
progress of all things good.
Because it is about actual understanding,
feeling states, intentions.
But I have to first mentalize about
me before I mentalize about you.
A way of putting this would be, if I'm
thinking about you before I'm thinking
about me, I'm on a fool's errand.
You have to start with the self.
And to try and attain clarity of self.
Or to realize that you can't.
It's a very important nuance.
If I know that, say there's trauma
in me about a certain thing.
And I know that I respond in ways
where sometimes my emotions get high.
And I can't quite think through it
all, which can happen to me with
references or something that's
encompassing a certain kind of trauma.
I want to be aware of that, right?
So this idea of not only being aware
of what you know about yourself, but
being aware that there are things
you don't know about yourself.
So if I know enough to know that
a certain kind of interaction
about a certain kind of trauma.
Really sets me to a place where I'm
not able to mentalize like I normally
would be, I'm sort of flying blind.
Then, good for me to know that, because
I don't know what that's doing to me.
So it's the last time to make conclusions.
So let's say I'm in that state.
Let's say I'm in that state because of
something that just happened, and now
we have some sort of conflict, right?
Then for me to realize, like,
well, what's going on in me?
I'm bringing to this a lack of clarity
because I'm really activated, right.
In that sense, the anxiety, the
tension in me has been raised.
The negative emotion, that
reflexive, negative affect, feeling
emotion has been raised in me.
And then I realize, like, I don't know
how it's going to go if we interact
about it now because I can't rely on me.
So, like, hey, can we
talk about this later?
The same way if you recognize
in the other that person who's
usually rational is all worked up,
recognize that in the other, right?
A nd maybe that person doesn't realize
that they still want to interact.
And you say, let's revisit this.
We're both kind of calm,
cool and collected, right?
So mentalization greases the wheels of
all progress, but like anything else
has to be deployed in a way that works.
And the way that works is I start with
me, then I go to you, and then I go to us.
Andrew Huberman: I'm fully on
board the start with me, then to
the other, and then to us model.
It makes total sense.
In fact, so much so that I'm starting to
build an image of my mind, where first
is kind of a rule, which is it starts
with self understanding, thoughtful,
structured inquiry along the lines of
the map that was laid out in episodes
one and two of this series and that we've
been alluding to numerous times today.
Paul Conti: Yes.
Andrew Huberman: And then there's a
second line or rule that I've got written
on this imaginary piece of paper in my
mind, where anytime I default to thinking
about another without first going to
my own map and exploring what's going
on with me, that my own map starts to
become blurry, like I'm losing access to
it and it potentially could disappear.
I'm just creating this in my own
mind as a way to create a little
bit of, I think, healthy anxiety.
Paul Conti: I like it.
Andrew Huberman: To really go
there first, paints the picture.
Paul Conti: Yes.
Andrew Huberman: And the purpose in having
such an image in my mind, that access
to the self and understanding of self is
potentially drifting away, is because I
think, for me, there's a third line in
this rule set that I'm imagining, which
is that the less understanding we have
of our own map and internal process,
the more likely I am, or we all are,
to just latch on to an unhealthy map.
Another unhealthy map.
Paul Conti: Yes.
I have to even follow the directions
o f our own unhealthy map.
Which leads us to someone else's
unhealthy map, and then we
latch onto it, like you said.
Yeah, absolutely.
Yes.
Andrew Huberman: Yeah, that's right.
Because it's still active, even
if it's blurry or if it's obscured
from my awareness and drifting away.
Paul Conti: So if I'm trying to guide
myself with my broken compass, I run
into someone else with a broken compass.
Now we're both wandering, so be aware.
If the compass isn't working the way
we want it to, can we go look at that?
Can we make the map healthy, make
the map accurate, make the map
guide us towards what we want?
Because then we will find other people
who've worked on their own maps that way.
Andrew Huberman: Absolutely.
And so often I hear about, and
frankly, I've experienced this
feeling like, oh, it's just a matter
of finding somebody who is healthy.
Right?
And then things will be
much easier and much better.
And surely that has to be the case.
And surely there have to be instances
where people have an interaction
with somebody that leads to a
relationship with somebody and the
other person is much healthier.
And whatever trauma we come to the
relationship with is best supported
or better supported than it would be
if we were with somebody exploitative
or who was truly damaged in some
way, who basically had a map that was
really, I don't want to say screwed
up, but that they had not explored.
Paul Conti: They need a lot of work.
Andrew Huberman: They need a lot of
work, but I don't see that very often.
I definitely see people who, at least
from my outside read, seem to have healthy
maps or are doing regular exploration
of their maps and therefore healthy.
Who knows?
I don't know what they do with
their time in every domain of life.
But once again, we come back to this
importance of understanding what's
in those cupboards, what's in those
pillars, as a not just important but
critical step in understanding and
building ourselves in positive ways.
And as I said once or twice before in this
series, but I'm going to say it again,
and I'm sure again and again before we
conclude this series, is that what's
so attractive about this map is that
it sets a very clear and simple set of
ideals, not necessarily simple to attain.
And as you've said, it takes time,
but agency, concept and gratitude,
empowerment, humility, leading up
to peace, contentment and delight,
all as action states, not as passive
states to just bask in and disappear.
And this notion of the generative drive.
And by now, in this episode, I'm sure
people are well on board the understanding
that the generative drive is not just
about going out and doing things.
It's about doing things in service to
and in a way that supports learning,
knowing, creating, not just of
others and in the world, but inside.
Paul Conti: Yes.
I love the map imagery because you can
almost see the map changing, right?
As the person, I imagine the person
is busying away in the cupboards.
Oh, there's a lot to
work on in this cupboard.
And they're busying away and they're doing
the work, and we can see the map changing.
That path that looked like a really
good path actually goes through a swamp.
We didn't see the swamp on the map.
Now it appears on the map.
That other path that looked
like it's a little circuitous.
That's a good path.
It might be a harder path.
It is a little circuitous, but
look where it leads, right?
The map becomes clear as we
do the work on ourselves.
Andrew Huberman: Yes.
And also the understanding that you've
laid out for us here really helps
avoid a lot of the common pitfalls that
are associated with sticky language.
And sticky for good reason.
I mean, what's stickier and more
interesting for people that are interested
in themselves, in relationship than
things like boundaries or labels like
anxious, attached, or secure, attached.
And I'm not being disparaging of
those labels, but I'm realizing
those are just labels, right?
They don't define action items and
specific lines of inquiry to get us back
into our self understanding over and over.
Not as a full time job, right?
We all have to live our lives, but
as a way actually to be more leaned
into life in the outside world.
Paul Conti: Those labels define people no
better than the numerical diagnoses in the
psychiatric taxonomy book that we glorify.
Labels are not understanding.
Numbers are not understanding.
They can help.
Taxonomies are good.
Sometimes labels let us categorize
things, but labels are not a
substitute for understanding.
Numbers are not a substitute
for understanding.
If we look at ourselves, we get
real understanding, and that's
what makes the difference.
That's what bolsters agency,
gratitude, all those good things.
Clear mentalization, greasing
the wheels of progress more, the
generative drive getting stronger.
We really can find goodness, and often do.
And that's why I think everything
we're t alking about is very hopeful.
It acknowledges there's complexity.
There are pitfalls.
There are all sorts of things to it that
we need to be aware of and to beware of.
But that doesn't mean that ultimately
it isn't positive that we're not
speaking to, hey, whatever it is that's
ailing you, that thing can be better.
Andrew Huberman: Well, I'm so grateful
that you're sharing your knowledge and
experience around all of this with us
and that you've laid out such a clear
and logical and deep and tractable,
really actionable understanding
of all this that we can engage in.
It's tremendously powerful.
Paul Conti: Thank you.
I so appreciate it.
Thank you.
Andrew Huberman: Thank you for joining
me for today's discussion about how
to improve your relationships with Dr.
Paul Conti.
I'd also like to take a moment to remind
you that the fourth episode in this series
on mental health with Paul Conti will be
out next week and that links to all the
episodes can be found at HubermanLab.com.
If you're learning from and or
enjoying this podcast, please
subscribe to our YouTube channel.
That's a terrific, zero
cost way to support us.
In addition, please subscribe to the
podcast on both Spotify and Apple.
And on both Spotify and Apple, you
can leave us up to a five star review.
Please also check out the sponsors
mentioned at the beginning and
throughout today's episode.
That's the best way to
support this podcast.
If you have questions for me or comments
about the podcast or guests that you'd
like me to consider hosting on the
Huberman Lab podcast, please put those
in the comments section on YouTube.
I do read all the comments, and if you're
not already following me on social media,
I am Huberman Lab on all platforms.
So that's Instagram, Twitter,
LinkedIn, Threads, and Facebook.
And on all those platforms I discuss
science and science related tools,
some of which overlap with the content
of the Huberman Lab podcast, but
much of which is distinct from the
content of the Huberman Lab podcast.
So again, it's Huberman Lab
on all social media channels.
Not on today's episode, but on many
previous episodes of the Huberman
Lab Podcast, we discuss supplements.
While supplements aren't necessary
for everybody, many people derive
tremendous benefit from them for
things like enhancing sleep, for
hormone support, and for focus.
If you'd like to see the
supplements discussed on the
Huberman Lab podcast, you can go to
livemomentous.com, spelled O-U-S.
So it's livemomentous.com/huberman.
If you haven't already subscribed
to our newsletter, it is a zero cost
newsletter called the Neural Network
Newsletter . And in the Neural
Network Newsletter you get free
podcast summaries as well as toolkits.
The toolkits are brief PDFs that
list off the specific science backed
protocols for things like improving
your sleep, improving focus, optimizing
dopamine, and deliberate cold exposure.
We have a complete summary of
our fitness series again, all
available, completely zero cost.
You simply go to hubermanlab.com, go
to the menu, scroll down to newsletter
and provide your email to sign up.
We do not share your email with anybody.
Thank you once again for joining
me for today's discussion with Dr.
Paul Conti.
And last but certainly not least,
thank you for your interest in science.
[Closing music]